>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Steve Winick: Again,
my name is Steve Winick.
I'm the editor here at the
American Folklife Center.
Actually my job title is
writer/editor and that comes
into play in the next thing
that I'm going to introduce,
which is the new edition of Folklife
and Fieldwork, which I think many
of you have been handed
out on your way in.
If you haven't, just
wave to a staff member
and someone will approach
you and hand you a copy.
But this is our fieldwork
manual and it has been
around for a good long time.
And in fact, the first
edition of Folklife
and Fieldwork was published in 1979.
And the author of that book was
Peter Bartis, who we are very lucky
to still have on the staff of the
American Folklife Center today.
And Peter and I were the co-authors
of this new version of the book.
And so, I just want to talk a little
bit about what's new in the book,
and also talk a little
bit about the history.
I think one of the nice things
about Peter and I being able
to collaborate on this is that
Peter was kind of an early student
and I was kind of a later student
of a man named Kenny Goldstein.
And Kenny Goldstein's dissertation
was called "A Guide for Fieldworkers
in Folklore", which
he then published
through his own publishing company
and it was the fieldwork guide
in folklore for years until, you
know, the sort of reflexivity
of looking at fieldwork became more
and more a thing within anthropology
and ethnography, and then a lot
of books on fieldwork came out.
But before that was the case, if you
wanted to know much about fieldwork,
you went to Kenny's book.
And so the fact that Peter distilled
a lot of the wisdom that he gotten
from Kenny and that I then got
to rework some of this as well
in this new edition was very
nice for both of us I think
to acknowledge Kenny's effect on us.
So what's new in the new edition
of Folklife and Fieldwork?
It's always been a great guide,
introductory guide on
how to do fieldwork.
And I know that a lot of people
who worked on our field projects
and then a lot of people
who've worked on field projects
and field schools that we've
run have used the book.
But we did make a few large
changes in the new edition.
In particular, we decided to make
it a little bit more chronological
so that we essentially
laid it out in the order
in which you would
think about things
when you're doing a
fieldwork project.
So you have to think about the
ethics up in advance, right,
before you actually
design the project,
so that's up toward the
beginning of the book.
So that made a big change in
the book from the old version.
And one thing that's nice about
that is that it allows the table
of contents to essentially be a
checklist of things that you have
to do on the way to doing
a fieldwork project.
So if you take a look at that,
you'll see that as one aspect
of the new nature of the book.
Second thing is that the tone
has gotten a little big lighter.
We are hoping for a kind of a
broader audience, maybe to be able
to use it with advance
undergraduate but also they use it
with graduate students
and with professionals.
And for that reason,
we adopted what I said
in the early production
meeting, I used the word breezy
and that became a kind
of a joke among us.
So this is the breezy version
of Folklife and Fieldwork.
And the third thing that
you'll notice is some issues
that we weren't able to talk
about at length in the book
but that we wanted to
introduce are brought
up in these little green text
boxes and it's kind of interesting
to hear a lot of the issues that
were brought up during the morning
and see how we dealt with some of
them in Folklife and Fieldwork.
So I'll say on page six, if
you want to flip to page six
on the very bottom, there's
a green box that says,
one of the first decisions
to make is whether
to do your fieldwork
alone or in a team.
Many of the best field projects in
the AFC archive were accomplished
by teams of fieldworkers
rather than individuals.
Teams allow you to divide the
labor, to document the process
of fieldwork, for example, by
photographing interviews in progress
and to brainstorm with teammates.
They also require you to negotiate
with your teammates beginning right
here with the goals of the project.
So again, we're putting that
in where you have to make
that decision, which
is when you're thinking
about what you actually
want to accomplish.
Another example is on page 11, when
we talk about the IRB and, you know,
the issue that if you're
at a university you may run
into this issue and you
have to be conscious of it.
So those are things that we try to
bring up this kind of both practical
and theoretical and ethical
concerns that you might have
and to bring them up in a way
that essentially directs you
to our website where we have larger
discussions of these issues for you.
So that's one thing to
say about the new book.
And then the other thing
is just that, you know,
it's gotten a new design look
so that it's in color now.
And we hope that that'll help
folks to interface with it.
You know, it'll make it
sort of more eye-catching.
So, that's Folklife and Fieldwork.
It is now a physical book which you
can hold in your hands as you see.
It's also a PDF which is going
up on our website as soon
as we can make it accessible.
So keep, you know, revisiting
our website and very soon,
within the next couple of weeks,
we're going to have Folklife
and Fieldwork up there as well.
So now--
>> How much does it cost?
>> Steve Winick: And it's free.
It's free of cost.
So if you are interested in
using this in your classes
or in using this for any kind of
field project that you're doing,
just give us a call or send us
an email at folklife@loc.gov
and we will send off to you
as many copies as you need.
We have taken delivery of 11,000
copies of this book today.
So, we have a few to give away.
So now, we're going to
move on to our next--
the next part of our symposium.
[ Inaudible Remark ]
Yeah. And this will be Nicole
Saylor is going to talk about audio
on the web, so come on up.
>> Nicole Saylor: Hello again.
All right.
The idea behind these
10-minute collection features is
to allow staff an opportunity to
highlight parts of the collection.
And since our AFC pre-1950s disc
recordings are so well-known,
I thought I'd move beyond what's
actually in the collection
and discuss how our
thoughts are developing
around making accessible
disc trove to scale.
So, I want to thank AFC staff,
many of them, Marsha, Todd, Maggie,
Jennifer, Steve, Judith, many
others who have deep knowledge
of this collection and
took the time to explain
and re-explain all the
idiosyncrasies of it
and its various iterations.
Oh, I need to drive.
OK. In short, the pre-1950s
disc collection includes seminal
fieldwork conducted by John
Lomax and his son, Alan.
During the time they worked
at the Library of Congress,
they recorded legendary
musicians such as Leadbelly,
Woody Guthrie and Jelly Roll Morton.
There's some other fieldwork
materials in there, Haiti fieldwork
from the '30s and work
from the Upper Midwest.
There's also other collectors'
materials, Herbert Halpert,
Zora Neale Hurston, Vance
Randolph and others.
So I've had friends and colleagues--
colleagues who weren't
archivists remark, you know,
that's just great stuff, you
should just put that online.
Yeah. Yeah, we should
and of course, we have.
We've started anyway.
But responsibly scaling access
to the collection online
is a major initiative
for us as I mentioned earlier.
But there are some hidden
complexities inherent
in mounting a large AV
collection that need to be sorted
out before we just put it online.
And so, I'll just walk you
through a few of those things.
OK, so first some context, right?
The date span of materials in our
archives ranges from 1890 to 2016.
So, that's about 125 years
worth of documentation
on every imaginable
audiovisual format.
So, we're a fairly contemporary
archive by many standards.
And so, the topic today
is the orange there.
It's the disc era which was
largely the '30s and '40s.
And so, I also mentioned descriptive
tools that help you access these,
and that's the card catalog.
And that was started in 1933.
I'll talk about that more later.
Because the Lomaxes were eager
to start publishing the material,
they collected right away and
they needed a way to organize it.
And so flash forward to 2007,
that card catalog information
went online.
So now flash forward to
2016, where we are today,
and we are a dozen years away from
marking the hundred year anniversary
of the archive founded in 1928.
The date for us, 2028, has come
to not only mark the anniversary
of the archive, but it sort of sits
out in the distance as a marker
for where we want to be
with our preservation work
on audiovisual materials.
So, the Library of Congress National
Recording Preservation Plan says
that many analog recordings must
be digitized within the next 15
to 20 years, and this is to avoid
degradation and obsolescence.
And so, we figured that by the
time we hit the hundred year mark,
we ought to have this problem
solved or at least well
in hand as much as we can.
So, this is why we are preparing
to conduct comprehensive assessment
of our AV holdings and start making
some moves toward seeking external
funding for ramping up that work.
OK. So in the digital world--
Well, in analog world, of course,
you've got two main pieces of
information from the field.
You've got the recording itself and
then you've got the field notes.
Now, often, they would use disc
sleeves to write information
about the recording and they
would sometimes use notebooks.
And I'm ignoring the fact that
they took photographs just
for simplicity's sake.
But yes, those are
the main components
of the fieldwork from this era.
So in the digital world, that turns
into audio files and metadata,
right, metadata, description
about data.
OK. So, WPA workers created the
catalog in the '30s and '40s,
and the archive staff then continued
to build it through the late 1960s.
It's still in our reading room.
It's kind of a cool artifact,
but it also does get active use.
People like to go to it even
though it is also online.
And here are the happy
people who made it go online.
Some of them are in
the room, I believe.
This was a real game
changer for the archives
and it remains a widely
used resource.
Not only was the information
transcribed into a database,
but the cards themselves were
imaged and included online.
So, the issue now is that the
database needs to be migrated
out of an old unsupported software
into a new library environment.
So, this seems like a
great opportunity to sort
of re-imagine what this would
look like with the sound attached.
So, v.3 as I like to call
it would be online access
to the whole shebang, except
it's a little complicated.
And a caveat, my numbers
are slightly squishy.
So, don't hold me to them, please.
But-- So, it should be noted
that we have more digitization
to do in the collection.
What happened in the late '60s
and early '70s was a wholesale
transfer of the discs to tape.
And so, we have these
materials on tape.
Now, we also have digital
copies of the tape.
We have digital copies of the disc.
Yeah. So, there's a little
bit of sorting out to do.
Two minutes, oh my
goodness, all right.
Well, I'm saving you from
some minutiae, right.
OK. Flash forward,
we have a digital--
we have the National
Audio-Visual Conservation Center
and a fabulous engineer
named Rob Cristarella
who works hard digitizing
the materials for us.
So when we consider what to do-- you
know, how to get this stuff online
in an efficient and
cost-effective way, we have to think
about things like, you know, do we
go to the source material which is,
of course, the better quality choice
typically but is more expensive
and time-consuming to transfer.
And we have to look at condition
issues across the two formats.
Is the reel good in this case,
is it better than the disc?
And so, there's a lot of evaluation
and there's also duplicates, right?
So, there are duplicate discs and--
anyway, so there's some things to
[inaudible] in an interest of time.
I almost killed this slide,
but it was too hilarious
so I had to keep it in.
I don't quite know how to
articulate it, but we have got--
So we've got two digital files
from side A and side B of a disc
for example, then you digitize
a reel, reel-to-reel tape
and you can get a file or
multiple files depending
on how it was ordered.
And then, the card catalog
has track-level information,
so yet a more granular, like
more granular than a disc side,
it has the various tracks
on a particular side.
So when you look to unite
these in a digital environment,
it's tricky to just put it briefly.
Anyway, so we think about, you know,
people zip up raw data
and they hang it online.
We're probably not going to
do that for various reasons.
And then, there's this what we
call hand-crafted where you sort
of sit there and preciously cut
out all your tracks and, you now,
edit your metadata which is now, OK.
So moving on, I'll just say
that we did a little experiment
with the Lomax in Michigan
materials.
We used-- We attempted a pilot,
More Product, Less Process,
it's what we call it in archives
land where you try to sort
of be a little less precious
and get more out there.
And so, we did things like we
took all these track-level records
and we smooshed them
into one record.
So, you'll see that the title
is like title colon, title--
I mean, so it's a little ugly.
The transfers are flat.
They aren't speed corrected.
They aren't anything.
They are also-- They're
not, you know, synced up
or time stamped to
the metadata at hand.
I'll stop there, thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Nancy Groce: Right.
And thanks very much, Nikki.
I'm Nancy Groce again and I'll be--
as I speak, actually the panelists
for this next panel
would like to come up.
Well, in no particular
order, I'm going--
We're going to be talking about
the Occupational Folklife Project
in particular and the
community engagement
and collecting in a digital age.
And while everybody
is taking their seat,
I'll just tell you a little bit
about this project which is--
was an innovative born
digital history documentary--
oral history documentation project
that the American Folklife Center
initiated in 2008 as in if--
initially, it's the American Works
project and was kind of conceived
at the height of the Great
Recession as an oral history project
to document the voices and
concerns of contemporary workers.
And it was honestly inspired by the
1930s WPA American Life Histories
and previous occupational histories
that are here at the library,
and we consider one of the
gems of our collection.
Occupational Folklore-- Folklife
collecting goes through periods
like any other trends
in folklore scholarship
and it's now ascending again.
For many years, people weren't
doing it for a number of reasons.
We can discuss during
the course of this panel.
But this-- the Occupational
Folklife Project was launched
in 2008 and started off.
Well, it was really aided by
the fact that Peggy Bulger
who was then the director of the
American Folklife Center arranged
for funding for Archie Green
Fellowships to be given
to people throughout-- through
a competitive scholar fellowship
program to people throughout
the country to do research
in their own communities and
share that material with us.
To date, we have almost
600 substantial interviews
with American workers from--
throughout the United States
and more being added to the
American Folklife Center's archives
every week.
And today's speakers
are all awardees
of the Archie Green Fellowship.
So, what I'm going to do
is I'll introduce them
and then we can perhaps take turns.
They'll each take about 10 minutes
to talk about their projects,
and we can-- and then have time for
some question and answer at the end.
So first, I'd like to introduce Bob
Bussel who's the associate professor
of history and director of
the Labor and Education Center
at the University of Oregon
and he's joined by Bobbie Sotin
of the Service Employees
International Local 503
in North Bend, Oregon.
And they designed and worked
on a 2015 Archie Green
Fellowship called Taking Care,
documenting the occupational
culture of home healthcare workers.
There is-- Next to them is
Candacy Taylor who's director
of Taylor Made Culture
in Los Angeles,
California who received a
2013 Archie Green Fellowship
to document hairdressers and
beauty shop culture in America.
Next to her is Maida Owens
from Louisiana Division of Arts
in Baton Rouge, Louisiana who
oversaw a team of researchers
for the 2014 Archie Green Fellowship
documenting Baton Rouge mall
businesses and trades.
And finally is Chris Mule from the
Brooklyn Arts Council in Brooklyn,
New York, who received the 2015
Archie Green Fellowship to work
with Domestic Workers
United in Brooklyn,
New York to document
domestic workers
in the New York Metropolitan
area, so very diverse.
And of the 30 some odd
projects that have been involved
with the Occupational Folklife
Project, we've been delighted
by both the geographic diversity
and the different occupations
that have been highlighted.
And we specifically-- we're
specifically delighted that most
of the one-- of the people and teams
who've gotten support are working
in trades and occupations that
are frankly underdocumented
at the American Folklore--
Folklife Center.
So, they're helping
us enrich our archive.
So with that, I'm going to go tramp
across the stage and take my seat.
And would you like to
start off with the Oregon--
>> Bob Bussel: Sure.
>> Nancy Groce: -- material?
OK.
>> Bob Bussel: Sure.
Well, thank you very much, Nancy.
And I just first want to say thank
you to the American Folklife Center
and the Library of Congress.
Nancy was a dream to work
with throughout this process.
So, thank you very much for that.
And I'm delighted to be joined
by Bobbie Sotin who's a
caregiver and also an interviewee.
So, we're going to
divide our time here
in talking briefly
about our project.
So, we also, in addition to Taking
Care, we started to call this work
and the things that are growing
out of it the quiet revolution
because caregiving people that
care for the elderly, disabled,
people that are physically or
developmentally disabled often work
in private homes and their
work isn't often seen.
They care for some of the most
vulnerable people in our society.
And oftentimes, their work was
not that well recognized or given
that much dignity or respect until
the advent in Oregon and elsewhere
of collective bargaining
and unionization.
So, that's part of
our story in addition
to documenting the occupational
culture of these workers.
We had a wonderful team
that worked on this project.
I want to also acknowledge
my colleague
at the Labor Education
Center, Helen Moss.
We had two folklorists,
Nathan Moore and Don Stacy.
And Don Stacy is himself
a home care worker,
and another videographer,
Sonia De La Cruz.
And also, we could not have done
this without the cooperation
of Service Employees International
Union Local 503 that represents
over 11,000 of these workers
in the state of Oregon.
So, I wanted to first answer
a couple of questions just
about the logistics of the
project as Nancy had requested
that we interviewed 35 workers,
24 were women, 11 were men.
It is an industry that tends
to be dominated by women.
And we tried within that relatively
small sample to get as much racial
and ethnic diversity as we could.
So, we interviewed workers
from Eastern Europe.
There are a group of workers that
increasingly have gotten involved
in home care, Latinos and some
African-Americans as well.
And we interviewed people from both
urban, rural and suburban areas.
So, we also tried for
geographic diversity.
And I would just say
I'm going to talk
about four major themes very briefly
that grew out of this research,
but I would just say this.
We'd share this with you
that one of our inside jokes
about the project was as we
got into this that we thought
that we should have brought tissue
or handkerchief boxes with us
or the interviewee should
have because invariably,
somebody almost broke down
into some level of tears
when we heard just these rich and
profound stories from these workers.
These interviews lasted
from a half hour to an hour.
So, let me just say a couple
of things about the interviews
and I'm going to use
little snippets of words
to convey what was
going on thematically.
One theme was the previous
experience with caregiving
as one worker put it, we were
always taking care of somebody.
Almost everybody we interviewed had
some experience, many people caring
for relatives, family members, it
was really something that seemed
in people's blood or DNA
that caregiving was something
that was familiar to them
and was not something
that seemed out of the ordinary.
So, they carry that on very
directly into their work.
It was an extension of who
they were and their identity.
Another piece of this was
a profound sense of mission
as one worker memorably put
it, this is work that is good
for the world and good
for your soul.
Many people talked
about giving consumers
or their clients the lives
they want, the lives they need.
Excuse me.
And one caregiver who cared for her
autistic child said, my son is going
to have a life due to this
type of work that we're doing.
I have a brief film clip I wanted
to ask you if you could cue up.
This is a home care
worker named Edward Smith,
and I think you'd get a sense
in this very brief film clip
about what this work
means in terms of mission.
Can we run that?
>> It's possible, so
much in [inaudible].
>> We keep in mind we are
taking care of disabled person,
always try to put yourself in their
shoes about what they can't do
and understanding that, you know, I
have legs, I am [inaudible] shoes.
>> I am her walking to the
mall, I am all those things.
[ Foreign Language ]
>> Bob Bussel: You could stop there.
>> I believe--
>> Bob Bussel: I'd love to show you
more, but I think you get a sense
from Edward's quote just
the meaning of this work.
And the worker who came on
afterwards was also talking
about how removing the stigmas
from people with disabilities,
a memorable quote from Nephtali
Garcia that disabled folks are not
from another planet or universe.
So, this sense about the mission
of the work was very powerful.
Someone else talked about an
amazing journey with each client,
the relationships, the deep
relationships that often develop
between caregivers and
the people they care for.
One example of this was giving
people a sense of choice.
So, bathing, you know, doing
the most intimate type of work
with people and the
emotional labor that goes
into that can be very difficult.
This homecare worker talked
about making it into a spa day,
that they would actually--
This was the way in which
that work was done with this person.
So, enormous amount of inventiveness
and creativity that we saw
in the occupational
culture of these workers.
And then finally, there's this
sense of making us bona fide workers
that the role of the
union, that getting a union,
being able to be viewed as a
professional as one worker put it
to follow-up to this project.
It will be called the
quiet revolution.
And we just think there's
lots of potential in terms
of showing this film, the film
clips and the documentary,
the various groups of stakeholders
all around Oregon and elsewhere.
We have a presentation lined up at
a major labor history conference.
Others in our team will
use this professionally,
so I would just conclude by
saying that the funding we got
from AFC is truly the gift
that's going to keep on giving.
Bobbie?
>> Bobbie Sotin: I've been a
homecare worker for 15 years,
and I have worked with
several seniors
and people with disabilities.
And it's been a heck of a ride.
When I first started,
we had no rights.
We had no workman's comp.
We had very little of anything until
our union came along and said, "Hey,
you know, if we organize you, we
can help and make things better."
So, not only has my union
helped with my career,
because I consider this a career
now, they also helped services
for the people I take care of.
We go to the capital every time
we get a chance to to tell them
and explain to them
exactly what homecare is.
And these videos are very helpful
on telling people or showing people
who we are and what we
do, and who we work for,
because I directly
work for these people.
They hire and fire me.
The state pays me but they can
hire and fire their workers.
And so, having this opportunity
to come here and say thank you
for what you're doing and letting
people know what homecare is
and what homecare does.
And I know the people that
I work for are very grateful
for having someone to stand
up for them and speak for them
when they're not able to.
So, that's one of the best things in
the world that is being able to come
to someone's house and say,
hey, let me, you know--
When I left she was crying because I
was going to be gone for four days.
So, it's a very rewarding job
and it's an important job.
And any time that your legislators
are asking you to pass a funding
for these kinds of programs,
please, it's important
that these people are taken care
of in a manner that's respectful
and honoring their service to
our community and our country.
Thanks.
[ Applause ]
>> Bob Bussel: See, I told
you about the handkerchief.
>> Nancy Groce: All right, Candacy?
>> Candacy Taylor: OK.
I'm going to go here
because I have slides.
>> Nancy Groce: OK.
>> Candacy Taylor:
Wonderful to be here.
Thank you so much for inviting me,
and thank you to the American
Folklife Center for this opportunity
for the grant to do this work.
It was such a gift.
I did a project called
American Hair,
the document of beauty shop culture
throughout the United States.
And I traveled over 20,000 miles
conducting interviews in salons
that served everyone from
African-American to Appalachian,
Cajun, Dominican, Gullah,
Japanese, Lumbee Indian, Pakistani.
I also interviewed some of
the industry powerhouses
like the Vidal Sassoon
family, Tabatha Coffey from
"Tabatha Takes Over",
Bob Marley's hairdresser,
Paul Mitchell and the like.
So let me see.
I'm going to advance.
OK. And I started this project
in 2006 because I was sitting
in my hair salon for about
10 years and realized
that in the whole time I'd been
there, I've never seen anybody
but black people in there.
And one day a white woman walked
in and wanted to get her hair done.
She just wanted to wash
and set, really simple.
And my hairdresser shooed her away.
Well, she was nice but she was
like, you know, no, I don't do that.
And then, when she
left, the woman left,
my hairdresser said,
I don't do white hair.
And I was shocked.
I was like, "Oh my god."
You know, I thought maybe this
is Gigi's exterior of the salon,
and I felt uncomfortable.
I was like, am I part of a secret
society that I don't know about?
Because I lived in San Francisco,
one of the most diverse places
in the world, and I just be-- it
was glaring how segregated it was.
And that's when I started
this project.
For the next several years, I just
would sit under the hair dryer
and just study what was
happening in the salon.
And I realized, you know,
I watched Gigi, our--
my hairdresser, counsel
us, support us.
I mean she-- Everybody went through
every kind of emotion imaginable
in that salon and Gigi
was there for us.
And I realized that she was
protecting this environment
that was rooted in
culture and ritual.
And I wondered, you know, if other
salons are like this, you know,
what about Japanese
salons or Pakistani salons.
And so, that's when
I got the opportunity
to do this project
when I got this grant.
And it was interesting because then
I had to go outside of my little,
you know, womb basically,
that was so protected,
into these other salons
are very intimate spaces.
And so, when I tried to go to see
a Chinese salon in San Francisco,
it was like, you know,
walking in and the music stops
and everybody looks at you,
like what are you doing here.
And I tell them I'm not
here to get my hair done
and they would just
be really relieved.
And that look of relief
would be like, oh god,
you know, then why are you here?
And when I would explain the
project, you know, I would just--
generally people were not, that
one out of eight, that's liberal,
would allow me to even
to do the project.
It was very hard to get access.
Having an outsider come in, I
mean, I'm there in their face
with this camera was, you
know, it was kind of invasive.
And ironically, after getting
the Library of Congress grant,
I thought, "Oh, this will
make it more important."
And I mean actually made it more
difficult because a lot the--
these were, you know,
immigrant-based communities,
these were small, you know,
they just heard government.
They were like, "Definitely not."
You know, we don't want to
have anything to do with that.
So, it was challenging.
But I continued on.
I continued to study the anatomy
of hair and understand that most
of the salons were segregated
because of hair texture.
You know, it wasn't just culture
but there was a logistical issue
of hairdressers not knowing how to
deal with that kind of hair texture.
And so, I learned about those
differences, the difference
between Asian hair and
why it's so hard to curl.
How it's, you know-- why
black hair just tends to be
so much kinkier and curlier.
I went to a Japanese salon and
saw-- it's actually in DC here.
And you can see how, you
know, this contraption,
there's all these chemicals, there's
all these things that they use
that the salon owner would have to
go to Japan to get these materials.
So, you know, it's not just--
I mean there's a comfort factor why
people group themselves, you know,
amongst people like them.
But then, there's this
logistical issue.
So, I learned about that.
And that, you know, easy
breezy kind of wave pattern,
that took about five hours for
her to get that, that look.
I also went to Bollywood Salon
which was Pakistani in Queens.
Shahzad here doing hair.
He said, you know, the most--
He probably did Jennifer Aniston's
haircut for 30 years of his career.
And it's very difficult
to get Indian hair
to fall like Jennifer Aniston.
So, he talked about that.
I looked at, you know, there's
this assumption that, oh,
the blond straight hair,
they have it easy and realize
that it's very time consuming
and expensive to be blond.
And that has its own
hurdles to deal with.
I was also very interested
in the labor involved
in doing hairdressing.
You know, I interviewed
Farrah Fawcett's hairdresser
and he said there's
75 steps to a haircut.
And so, he went through
that, just the architecture
of building a haircut and how much,
you know, knowledge goes into that.
I went to a traditional
African salon
and it was a home salon
in Philadelphia.
And that was one of the most
interesting interviews I did
because their hair-- it
wasn't just about the hair.
It was really, really tied to
their culture and identity.
And what they end up
doing a lot is trying
to fix black hair that's
been damaged
because of the straightening
and all the chemicals.
So here, Ifama is getting
braids, which is her natural hair
but at the top it's all extensions.
It's all fake hair until
her natural hair grows
out because she damaged it
so badly from chemicals.
And they were trained in these
traditional African hairstyles
so they had incredible knowledge.
And there's also I found
a white hairdresser
who has primarily black clientele.
Her name is Rina.
She's Sicilian.
So again in Sicily they tend to
have that kinkier texture hair
so she kind of wasn't afraid of
it and knew how to handle that.
So, she was amazing.
And you can see her
straightening, the transformation.
And I was also interested in
multicultural salons because,
you know, with the fact that,
you know, we're living in a world
where people are not of one
race, a lot of people choose
to say I'm not identified
with a particular race and one
in seven marriages or interracial.
So, we're looking at there's
different hair textures that are,
you know, just popping up
and people are demanding
to be served in regular salons.
They don't necessarily
want to go to a black salon
or a Chinese or Japanese salon.
So, there are multicultural
salons popping
up where the hairdressers are
trained to work on different types
of hair and people who are adopting
kids of a different race can go
into the same salon and get
their hair done as their child.
So, this is a big demand right now.
And Ms. Mia here is half Brazilian
and half black and, you know,
so her Brazilian mother who has
a straight hair is like, oh,
it's such a relief that I
can finally go to a salon
where we can both be served.
I was also looking at
Lumbee Indian women
and there's an African
bloodline in the Lumbeean tribe,
and so kinky hair does come up.
But this was a daughter of
a mother who had curly hair
and was really ashamed to have--
because all her brothers and
sisters had straight hair
that were traditional Indian
but she always hid her curls
and was really ashamed.
And now her daughter has this
curly hair and embracing her curls.
And so looking at the transformation
of time was also really was special
to see people changing
their identity around that.
And also, you know,
if you are-- have--
of Asian descent and
you want dreadlocks,
that's a whole process that,
you know, they have created
at Twisted Salon in New Orleans
where she had a steamer
nozzle attached to a hose and,
you know, and back combed.
And it was really complicated but
they could dread somebody's hair.
So, that was another shoe.
And I went to Orthodox
Jewish salon in Brooklyn
and thought I'd be walking into
some place that was so, you know,
I want to say repressed but
just, you know, very somber.
But they have one of the
leading, you know, salons of--
for wigs for people
of African descent.
People from all over the country buy
their wigs and they've really broken
onto the box of religion.
So I am running out of
time but this is it.
So, I just wanted to say again,
you know, thank you so much
for this opportunity to continue
to do this work., you know.
For more information
of my other projects,
you know, go to my website there.
I do have some book cards.
I have some, you know, information.
If you want to come up to me,
I'll give you information.
But again, I think without being
able to do the field research,
without getting the funding which
is very difficult to do to get
that kind of funding, this
is such a critical program
and this made all the
difference in my project.
So, thank you for your time.
[ Applause ]
[ Inaudible Remark ]
>> Maida Owens: OK.
I have slides also.
I used the Archie Green Fellowship
to support a larger project.
I wanted to document Baton Rouge.
The larger project is now
called Baton Rouge Traditions.
It's a small midsize southern
city that boom since World War II.
Over the years I've noticed
that all too many people
like to criticize Baton
Rouge, my hometown
and Louisiana's capital city.
People love the state and its
culture but some make an exception
about Baton Rouge, especially
cultural workers and researchers.
Many residents and
especially nonresidents think
that it lacks any expressions of
folk culture even though it is home
to an array of individuals
who maintain Louisiana's
defining traditions.
I started wondering why
Baton Rouge is perceived
as having no folk culture.
I knew that as the capital
city, it is a cultural microcosm
with people coming from
across the state to work.
Others have moved here from
throughout the United States
for employment at the
universities and industry.
I began to realize that Baton
Rouge had a major identity issue.
It doesn't help that Baton Rouge
is sandwiched between New Orleans
and Lafayette, two cities that are
known for their traditional culture.
The rapid increase in
population coincide
with the growth of suburbia.
The region includes urban, suburban,
and rural areas in addition
to small towns that are closely
connected to the city creating a web
of relationships and networks.
As the economic hub of the region,
its population density allows
specialized businesses to exist
that otherwise, would
be difficult to sustain.
And thus, the Baton Rouge
Folklife survey was born.
Elsewhere, I explore the
identity issues in greater detail
but today I'd like to look
at the occupational folklore
that we documented with support
of the Archie Green Fellowship.
I received this in partnership with
the Louisiana Folklore Society.
Maybe not.
>> Nancy Groce: Yeah.
>> Maida Owens: I have
to point somewhere.
[ Inaudible Remark ]
>> Bob Bussel: Since
he doesn't have them.
>> Nancy Groce: What?
>> Said he don't have
slides for you.
>> Maida Owens: Oh, I sent them, OK.
Since 2013, 12 researchers
documented tradition bearers
and wrote 21 essays
for the larger project.
Together the essays create
a virtual book called the
"Baton Rouge Traditions".
The virtual book includes an
introduction by me in six chapters,
Baton Rouge Gives, Baton
Rouge Makes, Plays,
Worships, Works and Diversifies.
Each essay features photographs
and most have audio clips
from the interviews.
Essay is based on fieldwork
supported by the project
to have field reports that
are available upon request
and offer more details.
Baton Rouge works includes
essays on occupational folklore.
The Archie Green Fellowship enabled
us to focus on people employed
in small businesses and trades
who have specialized skills.
Two of the field workers had
already done work in Baton Rouge.
Douglas Manger and Laura Marcus
Green are both senior folklorists
who have vast experience
with contract fieldwork.
One reason that I chose them
is that they had no experience
in Louisiana or even the south.
So they came with little to no
preconceived ideas about the city.
This fresh perspective
was significant
in that they noticed
things about the city
that I had overlooked
or took for granted.
For example, the abundance
of beauty parlors,
barber shops, and nail salons.
I assigned projects in part based
on the strengths and interest
of each researcher and
provided a list of possibilities
but the field workers
contributed ideas and I was open
to the serendipity of fieldwork.
Douglas Manger documented a
taxidermist, barber, funeral home,
custom sign maker, piano
tuner, and a clothier.
He also looked at restaurateur
[inaudible]
and how he used his welding skills
to creatively solve problems
for his restaurant and
food processing business.
Laura Marcus Green did two projects.
She looked at bakeries
and specialized cakes
including groom's cakes
and the emerging tradition of cakes
that announce a baby's gender.
She also documented shop owners
who specialized in hats and dresses
for African-American
women to wear to church.
Jocelyn and Jon Donlon are a
folklorist photographer team
formerly based in Baton Rouge so
they were familiar with the city.
And have-- They've done
other contracts for me.
With this project, they focused on
repair services, shoes, furniture,
rods and reels, instruments and
jewelry in addition to a locksmith,
a baton maker, and clothier.
A fourth field worker contributed
to the Archie Green
collection as a volunteer.
Maria Zorang [assumed
spelling] interned
with me during summer 2013 before
starting her PhD work at IU.
She came to the project
familiar with Baton Rouge
and documented ethnic grocers,
Buddha makers, and tea cake makers.
All field workers had difficulty
documenting small businesses,
especially if the person to
document was not the business owner.
The first to confront this
issue was Maria Zorang who had
to abandon her original goal
of documenting butchers.
She was not successful in
getting any meat markets
to allow their butcher to
be interviewed on work time
and then the owners did not
want to ask their employees
to do it on their own time.
So they simply declined.
Many small business owners
clearly saw time as money
and did not perceive being
included in this documentation
as a worthwhile use of their money.
And we even had letters
of introduction
from the lieutenant governor,
you know, things like that.
But all of them had trouble.
With more time and other strategies,
no doubt we could have figured
out how to get access to butchers.
But she had to complete
the fieldwork that summer,
and so redirected her energies.
She put in an extraordinary
effort and can't be faulted
for not trying hard enough.
She would come in every day-- You
know, she worked out of my office.
So every day I heard the
tales of what she was trying.
She cannot be faulted.
Nonetheless, I thought more
experienced contract field workers
might not have this problem.
I was wrong.
All three other projects
had more declined interviews
than I have ever seen in a project.
But all persisted and were able
to contribute the interviews
for the collection.
After each project is completed, I
post the essay online and share it
with the interviewees
for their review.
Some request clarifications,
some never respond at all,
occasionally they want additions,
photographs added or such.
The next step is to publicly
present the results in other ways.
Since the folklife program
does not have the resources
to present the traditions
to the public other
than through the online essays, I
partner with the local arts agency
so that they can incorporate
it into their programming
and expand their constituency.
They're ecstatic with the work.
But again, we haven't, you know,
the flood actually is a major issue.
The project has not been
officially announced
so that the work is just beginning.
And the flooding has impacted
the region so profoundly
that we are postponing
the announcement and how--
and determining how to announce it.
Despite documenting 259 tradition
barriers over the larger project,
there were many that
did not get included.
Some of the occupational
traditions include welders
who fabricate custom outdoor cooking
equipment used for crawfish boils
and other catering businesses.
Other small repair
businesses such as watch repair
and many other food businesses such
as seafood market, snowball stands
and of course butcher shops.
Finally the building
trades need to be looked at.
It won't be easy to change the
perception about Baton Rouge.
This summer I got a reminder
when I presented to a group
of educators in nearby Lafayette.
I shared the rich traditions that
we had found in Baton Rouge and said
that their students might
find similar traditions
in their hometowns.
Afterwards one told me that,
well, it was a good project.
The problem is that Baton Rouge
just does not have a soul.
I suspect that this midsize southern
capital city's identity is conflated
with people's frustration
with state government.
The city's horrid traffic and having
to attend dreaded statewide
required meetings.
Perception about Baton Rouge
will not change easily.
But hopefully this project will give
civic leaders more data to consider
and expand their concept
of what folk traditions are
in the city and the region.
And I would again like to thank, you
know, for receiving the fellowship.
We would not have been able to
explore these subjects without him.
[ Applause ]
[ Inaudible Remark ]
>> Chris Mule: I'm going to sit.
Yeah. But I can use this, right?
>> Nancy Groce: OK.
>> Chris Mule: This.
OK. So, hi, my name is Chris
from the Brooklyn Arts Council.
And I worked with the team in
Brooklyn on a project called
"Preserving and protecting
the domestic workforce".
I worked with a group of
domestic workers called Domestic
Workers United.
Before we get there,
I'm going to talk
about what is a domestic worker.
Someone who works in another
person's home and cares
for their children or an
elderly person, is a housekeeper,
does other work in or around the
home like gardening or repair work.
Domestic Workers United is a
membership based organization.
They're not a union.
They are base of Caribbean, Latina
and African nannies, housekeepers
and elderly caregivers in New
York, organizing for power, respect
and fair labor standards to end
exploitation and oppression.
So the two key terms here are
trying to fight for recognition
that this work is real work.
As of today, DWU, that's
how I'm going to refer
to Domestic Workers United,
has organized over
6000 domestic workers.
There's an estimated 300,000
domestic workers in New York State.
So the goals as I mentioned,
Domestic Workers United wants
to make sure there is equal
rights for domestic workers,
but the recognition of the
occupation of as real work.
One of the common phrases
you hear them talk about is
that they do the work that
makes all other work possible.
They work for very wealthy
lawyers, doctors, you name it,
in New York City, Long
Island as well.
And in 2010-- So Domestic
Workers United started in 2000.
In 2010, they passed something
called the Domestic Workers Bill
of Rights.
So this bill of rights was
to guide domestic workers
and have them communicate
their rights
to avoid harassment on the job.
Sexual harassment or harassment
based on gender or ethnicity
to advocate and to understand
that they get days off.
That once they work
over-- And also, yeah,
once they work a certain amount
of time, they're required
to have one day off a week
at least if they're in--
they're working in-house
or a live-in.
They are required to have 24 full
hours off of that seven days.
It taught domestic workers
to use their rights,
how to advocate the fact that
they have rights and reinforce
that the rights applied to
domestic workers regardless
of immigration status.
And this is the key
thing for all the workers
that Domestic Workers United worked
with because they don't have--
Many of them, I'd say I think 75%
of the ones we interviewed
do not have--
their immigration statuses
is cloudy and difficult
that they don't have the ability
to advocate for themselves.
They're afraid.
They're afraid to-- When their
employer ask them to walk the dog
which is like the worst thing
you can do for a Caribbean woman
to ask them to walk a dog.
And so when they're asked to do
that separate job that's different
than being a nanny, but they're
not going to say no to it
because they're afraid to get fired.
They don't know where
their next job might be.
Many times this status,
their immigration status
has been used against them.
And they've been-- that people
might threaten them that, you know,
if you don't do this and if
you don't work, you know,
seven days a week then
I'll report you.
Even now they do-- So
they do have rights.
That doesn't really mean anything.
They shouldn't be afraid.
So Domestic Workers
United, that's a big thing.
So this project, the idea of working
with on this particular issue
and that the fact that there
is-- it's such a sensitive issue
and there's so much trauma involved
in the way these workers are
treated, we assembled a team.
So the first couple, the first
women that you'll see there,
that's Christine Lewis on the
left and Patricia Francois.
They are the leaders of
Domestic Workers United.
They would be the lead
interviewers and organizers
of this whole Archie Green project.
The next woman is-- I forget
her-- Ramone [assumed spelling],
and she is a-- who also works
for Domestic Workers United.
She is from Dominica, but her
mother was a domestic worker.
A key component of this was
also, you know, how do you manage
as a domestic worker
your own family.
So she was able to really help
us understand that aspect.
Ninaj Raoul is the next
woman on the right.
She runs an organization called
Haitian Women for Asian Refugees.
And she is-- was the one
who actually connected me
with Domestic Workers United.
There's a lot, there's a large
Haitian community in Brooklyn.
So she was instrumental in
making getting us to connect
with the Haitian population,
but also understanding
that she works a lot with
the immigration status.
So understanding how to-- one of
the things that she advocates for is
that these women talk about
their immigration status.
That it's OK.
So she brought a lot of information
and a lot of help and guidance
for this process when we had them
talk about their immigration status
and what types of things
have been used against them.
The next woman on the
bottom is Eileen Condon.
She works for-- used
to work for the Center
for Traditional Music and Dance.
They run these wonderful
things called community
cultural initiative.
So she really understand, you
know, community organizing,
how to make sure that all
sides are heard in the process
of creating a project
or any type of project.
So she was instrumental.
That's me in the middle.
And then Kaitlin McClure is a--
she was a grad student and she
did a lot of transcription for us.
So the methodology is taken
directly from Carl Lindahl's idea
of survivor interviews
during her legends
from hurricane Katrina, I think.
>> Right, on Katrina.
>> Chris Mule: So the idea that as
I mentioned earlier that it would be
so difficult for me to sit there
and do interviews not
understanding all the aspects
that these domestic
workers go through.
And I thought that if we did
a worker to worker interview,
it would be more effective.
It would be a great opportunity
for them to talk to each other,
to explore new issues, new ideas.
So in this process, I'm
sort of behind the camera.
Occasionally, I would jump in and
ask to pull out certain questions.
But we worked for about three
months creating a list of questions
that they're all happy with.
That dealt with a variety
of different issues.
And one of the-- just to sum it
up, one aspect we're interested
in is domestic work, domestic
workers inside the home.
So what skill and techniques does
it require to be a domestic worker?
What knowledge do you need?
What sort of communication
happens between you and the elder
that you're caring for or the child?
Relationship management is
probably the biggest skill needed
to be a domestic worker.
Relationship management with
your employer, with the child
or elder you're caring for
and relationship management
with your own family
during this process.
You would think that the
goal would be to make sure
that you have the kid--
that the kids love you
and that they almost call you mom.
But many different
workers had different ideas
about how to keep their guard up.
A real good domestic worker,
many people would think,
is you keep your guard up.
You don't-- You make
sure that a child--
that you don't develop
that type of relationship
because that can be very
difficult for you and the child.
Relationship management
with employers is the
hardest part of this.
That was always the difficult
stories about wage theft
and exploitation, assault, a variety
of awful things that
I won't get into.
Cultural expressions and conflict.
So many of these women, I'd say the
majority of them from the Caribbean,
they talked a lot about the
expressions that they brought
to the table, whether it's the food
they cooked or the stories they tell
or the songs they told and
how that could be currency.
But also it could cause conflict
when you're a woman that's working
in an orthodox household,
your cultural expressions
are curved immensely, so--
And when you're working for--
with kosher food, that can be--
They talked a lot about the
difficulty in navigating that world.
And also grievances,
that was the one thing
that Domestic Workers United was
interested in this project for is
to get these women to talk about the
difficulties they have on the job
to make sure that those
were expressed.
So, John, could you press play.
This is Patricia Francois
on the left
and Christine Lewis on the right.
Christine Lewis is
being interviewed.
Go for it.
>> Christine Lewis: You know what?
When I was growing up my
parents are working class people.
We had people who came
to see about us.
Who comb my hair, who make
sure my clothes was ironed.
I don't think when I leave
Trinidad I would come and work
in somebody's home or
care for somebody's baby.
And by the way, the article
in Trinidad newspaper,
before I leave Trinidad
once, do you know--
and I'm talking for
Trinidad, young women.
I don't know what the
other people would say.
>> Patricia Francois: Yes.
>> Christine Lewis: Do you know what
Trinidad young women are selling
their house and land
to go to America to do?
Walk peoples' baby on
the upper west side.
There it was and you
ask me that was me.
I rode that donkey years ago.
>> Patricia Francois: Yes.
>> Christine Lewis: And the shame
that is attached to domestic work.
But you know what?
As I look back on-- and the
[inaudible] you get from belonging
to a movement is that
all work is good.
The Father created the universe,
and when he created the
universe what do you see?
The seven days that
he saw his creation
in the [inaudible],
he said it was good.
>> Patricia Francois: Yes.
>> Christine Lewis: Doesn't
matter [inaudible] be the best,
that's what you could do.
Trust me, when I work for
the children that I work for,
I do the best that I could.
You know what?
You know what is my joie de vivre?
Let me tell you what
is my joie de vivre.
When the mother comes
home and this little boy,
he is holding on to his mother but
he is looking around for Christine
with a beautiful smile on his face.
The mother don't even have
to ask him how his day was.
the smile tells it.
>> Patricia Francois: Yes.
>> Christine Lewis:
The treatment he gets
when she's not there,
I treat him as my own.
How could you not love innocence?
So, yes. So this bill of
rights, who doesn't recommend--
recompense me for the love.
You can't pay for love.
You can't pay for unconditional
love that I wish sometimes
that these people would look at the
work that we do for loving a child,
for taking care of your home.
>> Patricia Francois: Yes.
>> Christine Lewis: Making sure
that when you come back
this child is scratchless.
He does not have a mark
on his, on his thigh.
>> Patricia Francois: Just happy.
>> Christine Lewis:
But he's just happy.
>> Patricia Francois: Yeah.
>> Chris Mule: So the next
part about that we're looking
to is their lives outside
of the home.
So, dual parenting.
If you're a domestic worker
and you're taking care
of your own family, how does
that impact your own family
if you're working seven days
a week for another family
and giving love to another child.
And education, what types of
skills were these women interested
in acquiring?
Who we choose to interview.
We interviewed Domestic
Worker United members.
Also day laborers,
there is a lot of--
There was two women we interviewed
from Ecuador that were day laborers
and worked-- stood on the street and
got picked up in South Williamsburg
and worked with orthodox families.
Haitian refugees, licensed
daycare providers provide us a way
as we realize what is it like
to talk to someone who works
on a regulated daycare industry.
And also special needs caregivers.
A lot of these women would take jobs
not knowing that they were going
to be caring for an autistic child.
Two of them were in that situation.
They didn't get paid any more nor
did they necessarily have the skills
but they rose to the occasion.
Access outside the LOC.
So I was thinking about
this like what would this--
what would be a good way to use this
information and how can the Library
of Congress deal with it.
So this idea of pain
porn is something
that you might hear something
about like poverty porn
where people are showing
oral histories or stories
that are meant to make you cry.
And that's something
that this and not--
If it's not put in the right
context, that with this--
That's what this stuff can
be used for but there's
so much more nuance
to these stories.
And I fear that it's very important
to make sure that they're shown
in the right context
and shown locally
for a particular community
that empowers them.
So I worry if it was just thrown
up on the web that it might be used
in a way that is not going
to help the movement.
And that's what I'm
talking about is, you know,
how can we work together with these
local organizations to make sure
that if the Library of
Congress is giving access to it,
that it's in cooperation with
domestic workers in New York State
or throughout the country, to
make sure that that happens.
I'm not going to play this.
It was received well.
It gave them a chance to talk.
The women were also paid to do
the interviews and be interviewed.
And this is going to be great
material for this organization,
Domestic Workers United, to
build their movement, to build--
We've talked about doing an exhibit
where they can organize people,
because really this is just an
organizing organization to try
to get people to be mobilized
and understand their rights.
And that's it.
Thank you.
>> Nancy Groce: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
We have a little time for questions.
Would you entertain some questions?
We have--
Oh, alright.
>> I mean thinking back-- hello?
>> Nancy Groce: Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> Thinking back to our
discussion earlier today
about the team projects,
I'm wondering to what extent
say Chris's project and Bob
and Bobbie's, was there any
opportunity for cross fertilization,
for learning from the experience
of the other project or Maida
and Candacy or is working
immediately some
of the Baton Rouge things
touched on the same topics.
Does the Archie Green Fellowship
and the Occupational Folklife
Program provide those formal
and opportunities or is
it just Nancy's you ought
to talk to x, y, or z?
>> Nancy Groce: Yeah.
I'm not trying to understand
the question.
You mean talking with the--
>> How are you working with--
>> Bob Bussel: Yeah.
>> Chris's project I
think came a year or two
after the Oregon project.
>> Nancy Groce: Right.
>> Did you have access to their
lessons, their experiences or,
you know, were you reinventing
finding your own way and anything--
>> Nancy Groce: Oh, you mean
across different projects?
>> Among the researchers--
>> Nancy Groce: -- project.
>> Correct.
>> Nancy Groce: Occasionally, very
often these come as local projects
with a real community in
sense of point of view.
These will eventually
be available online.
Right now they're not.
So, in some cases you heard-- I
forget-- it really depends on the--
I don't routinely-- because this
is competitive and people apply
and are evaluated by the outside
panel of-- and are awarded.
Sometimes I do put people in
touch with similar projects
that have occurred before.
Sometimes I'm not in touch with
the applicants before the awards
are given.
If there's a relevant project,
I often will try to hook them
up after they receive the award.
But because of its-- We're
responding to applications
from the field, it's-- There's only
so much control we have over it.
Did I answer your-- Yeah.
All right, and I forget, did I
put you in touch with each other?
I think I had--
>> Chris Mule: I don't know.
>> Nancy Groce: Did I
have you talk to Bob?
>> Chris Mule: I don't think so.
We didn't talk but now we can.
>> Bob Bussel: Because I
would say I mean it's just--
>> Nancy Groce: You can say
I want to talk to you after.
>> Chris Mule: Yeah.
Yeah, now it's--
>> Bob Bussel: There's
so much overlap--
>> Chris Mule: Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
>> Bob Bussel: -- you
know, with our projects.
That's really exciting.
I mean I would just say
that there have been people
who were considering applying for
Archie Green grants that, you know,
did get in touch with us.
And so we had some
fruitful conversations
about just our experience with the
program and any pointers we had.
So, you know, those were
really conversations, and yeah,
I look forward to this dialog--
>> Chris Mule: Yeah.
>> Bob Bussel: -- whenever you--
>> Chris Mule: Definitely.
>> Nancy Groce: Other questions?
Do you have questions
for each other?
>> Bobbie Sotin: Just that I
want to talk to him afterwards.
[ Laughter ]
>> Chris Mule: Cool.
>> Candacy Taylor:
We've got a question.
>> Tom Connors: Hi, I'm Tom Connors.
I'm with the Teamsters Labor
History and Archives Project.
And it's interesting that,
Chris, you said upfront
that the Domestic Workers
United is not a union--
>> Chris Mule: Right.
>> Tom Connors: -- yet
and doing the same sort
of work that Bobbie is doing.
Is it because that you're--
Bobbie, you're getting state money
and with these people,
Chris, that there are
so many different employers
that are--
There's no way to have
an election [inaudible]?
>> Bobbie Sotin: Well,
I'll tell you one thing.
It's really hard to organize
people who are in individual homes.
It's a tough job.
It's a lot of work to
get people to organize.
Are you-- 503 is working on projects
right now to find a way for people
to join a union, our union,
without being in a local.
So they can have a-- So they can
contribute to changing society
and getting people
to understand what--
what needs aren't being
met out there.
So, I believe 503 is-- probably
would love to talk to you.
So that's the reason why I
wanted to talk to you afterwards.
>> Chris Mule: Yeah.
>> Nancy Groce: I have to
say having listened to a lot
of your interviews, if I'm ever
sick, I'm moving to Oregon.
>> Bobbie Sotin: We
would love to have you.
>> Nancy Groce: So it was just
so-- The people are so eloquent
and so caring about their
charges and what it meant to them
and meant to their community.
It was very heartening to
listen to your interviews.
>> Bobbie Sotin: If you ever--
If people out there watch the news
you will see Oregon is a leader
in changing the country.
And we continue-- And that we
are getting a lot of flack,
a lot of people are putting money
into initiatives and stuff to try
to stop things from passing.
But Oregonians are a
little hard to convince
that we don't need what we need
and they're spending lots of money
that are probably is
going down the toilet.
That's what I-- That's
what I'm hoping.
>> Nancy Groce: Yes?
>> Thank you for a wonderful,
wonderful presentation.
I mean I just find
it all fascinating.
And one of the things that I'm
thinking about is the neighborhood
where I live which is very diverse.
There are a lot of people that are
barely making ends meet to those
who aren't-- who are doing alright
but it's a very diverse community,
a good number of immigrants
and a number of our neighbors
that we've gotten to know
do a lot of domestic work.
They're working in
homes with individuals,
either people with disabilities
or taking care of children.
And it's been really
fascinating getting to know them.
And what this does for
me is it challenges me
to think more about
their experiences.
I already have some insights
in terms of the complexities
and disadvantages and even at times
mistreatment of these individuals.
So my question is as just being
a neighbor to people that come
from these workgroups, what can
somebody like myself who feels
like they're being
increasingly educated
through this work do
to apply this at home?
What can I say to them to
say, hey, you're not alone,
look what's happening
here over there.
Can you help me with that?
>> Chris Mule: That's it.
>> Bobbie Sotin: I would say
put them in touch with 503.
>> Bob Bussel: Yeah.
>> Nancy Groce: It might
be outside the scope
of this particular project, but
I think it's a good question.
Maybe something we could discuss
over break which I think we have--
which we might go to right now.
Why don't we-- Why
don't we take a break
and discuss this further and-- Yes?
Oh, I'm sorry.
Does the panel with-- Yeah.
I should know this.
So, all the more reason that
we'll-- We'll go to the next panel.
And I want to thank everybody for
coming and this has been great.
Thank you so much.
>> Chris Mule: Thank you.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Nicole Saylor: All right, today
you're going to hear from two people
who are leading large scale
collecting efforts that end
up in a national library.
There are two very different models
and they're leveraging
technology to do the work.
You'll first hear from
Kevin Bradley.
He's the senior curator
of research collections
and unpublished materials at the
National Library of Australia,
and then you'll hear from Virginia
Millington who is the recording
and archive director at StoryCorps.
All right.
Take it away.
I'm so sorry.
>> Kevin Bradley: That's all right.
And I'm just going to wait a second
for the right dramatic impact
and my slides to start.
OK, in 1902, the newly established
Australian Parliament passed the
Commonwealth Franchise Act, which
said a uniform law entitling women
to vote in federal elections and to
stand for the federal parliament.
We were the second country
in the world to allow women
to vote in national elections.
New Zealand was the first.
And then those of you who
know anything about Australia
and New Zealand know that
we have a great rivalry.
So, I would like to say that women
were not eligible to be elected
in the House of Representatives
in New Zealand until 1919.
So we can claim a very
tiny moral high ground.
The picture you're looking at
over there is the Regatta Hotel
which overlooks the Brisbane
River in Brisbane Queensland.
So, you're asking yourself,
I know you are,
"How were these two
things connected?"
Why did I tell you this
piece of information
and show you the picture.
Well, I didn't want you to think
the country was run by prejudiced
and chauvinistic individuals when
I tell you that up until 1965,
it was illegal for women
to be served drinks
in the public bar of
a licensed hotel.
In 1964-- '65, the law was changed
after two women chained themselves
to the bar at the Regatta Hotel.
Their action, laugh you may, their
action is now recognized as one
of the defining moments of second
wave feminism in Australia.
And I hope the fact about the
women's suffrage might mitigate
slightly against the
embarrassing announcement.
The second reason is it was
in this bar that after the end
of the successful meeting of
the Oral History Association
of Australia, Al Thompson, noted
oral historian and professor
of history at Monash University,
and I were having a drink
in what is now called Merle's
bar in honor of Merle Thornton,
the woman you see chained
to the bar there.
Al was watching his team
lose the grand finals
in the Australian Rules Football,
and I was trying to convince him
that we needed a large scale
oral history survey project
to document social
change in Australia.
Part of my argument
was to use the example
that public opinion
regarding attitudes
to women drinking in
bars had so changed.
That at this time, people can't
imagine was ever any other way.
It has been so naturalized.
And in fact, I was explaining to one
of my young staff what it was we're
doing and she was horrified to think
that this was true and your
own mother would have known
this situation.
So this sort of cultural
forgetting is going on all the time
and a large survey
project was needed.
For me, it was fill of
gap in our collection,
an update to a previous project
and Al agreed and led the project.
He described it as to be a
major project to investigate
into generational dynamics
and impact of dramatic social,
technological and environmental
changes on the experience
and attitudes of succeeding
Australian generations.
And he was able just prior
to starting the project
to win a National Library fellowship
so that he can investigate the
1938 project which was run in 1988,
which was the last similar
project to be run in Australia.
Now, the project wasn't
run on its own.
I listed here the many projects
would have been undertaken
in the past few years.
Some projects have concentrated
on specific periods and events
like bush fires, or
unemployed drivers,
members of religious
orders and so on.
Some have been to nationally
significant issues
such as cultural context of
unemployment, Australia's response
to AIDS, the Bringing
Them Home project
about the indigenous
stolen generation,
and the Forgotten Australians
and Former Child Migrants.
Those brought up in care.
Generations project,
the one that's sort
of in this discussion is
the focus of the discussion
and what we're talking about but it
shouldn't be considered on its own.
It's part of a larger collection
or a larger set of projects as well
as what it finds on its own.
So, the National Library,
all our interviews are
what we term hall of life.
That is we try to embed
the topic we are pursuing
in the context of a life trajectory.
Their interviews with Australians
who ensure their life stories,
memories, perspectives
and personal insights,
which in short say that
these are captured.
We plan for all our interviews
to be around five hours long,
some are shorter, most
are significant longer--
significantly longer.
If the interviewee wants to talk,
we try to accommodate them even
though our interviewers will be
there to guide them.
Interviewers-- interviews
are a negotiation
but the interviewee should
be in the driver's seat.
And if they don't like the
interview, they have the right
to destroy it at any time.
We have a true-- two-day training
for our generations project
and all our interviewers are already
very experienced interviewers
when they begin.
Each interview focused on
a person's life history
but for this particular
project, we had some themes
that we wanted to pick up as well.
And so, those themes included
like faith and belief,
family and friends, place,
belonging, growing older, difference
or disability, leisure, play time,
technological transformations
and so on.
Other themes grew out of
the interviews and one
which surprised us all was the
occurrence in many interviews
of a deep and personal
discussion of mental health.
Right. The interviewee has control
over the recordings
for their lifetime.
Unpublished collections are
acquired from individuals
and this is from our themes.
Generally, unpublished collections
require an ongoing relationship
with the creators and
[inaudible] for their ease of use.
We ingest the standards right forms
into our information
collection management system
and we manage them accordingly.
Our project is selective.
Unpublished collecting is
highly selective by its nature.
Using-- There is no complete
set unless it's everybody.
Using the priorities outlined
in the library's principal
library staff exercise judgment
to determine the significance
of materials
and the research documentary or
historical value of a collection.
But once we say we're going to
look at a topic or a subject,
we look across our collection.
We look for papers.
We look for photographs.
We look for the whole to embed an
entire research archive within them.
The most valuable part of
the IRC research project is
that we can bring a range
of expertise to all sorts
of projects issues of which
the selection process is an
important one.
I still have five minutes.
I've just made it to six.
Generations.
We had far more volunteer to be
interviewed than we can possibly do
and perhaps you can ask
me about that later.
It was-- The Australians
Generations Project was funded
by the Australian Research Council,
which is a way of funding it
and had two universities
within there,
the Australian Broadcasting
Corporation
and National Library as partners.
It ran over four years,
created around 2000 hours
of oral history interviews,
and all the interviews
had time pointed summaries
like Doug was describing before.
We had a similar sort of system that
we developed I think slightly ahead
of you Doug but-- See, there's
another moral high ground.
And we supplied all the
audio recording equipment
and all the files are recorded
at broadcast word files to allow
for long-term preservation.
Two last points, we innovated
because we used a system called
Zotero for the researches.
We packaged up those time pointed
summaries with all the information
and the audio, and then you could--
The researchers could have access
to that material only
and search the content.
And then annotate them and share
the information between each other
as they worked on the project
so it was a constrained part.
And what we produced in the
end apart from the interviews,
which was the main part, there were
a series of national radio programs,
a number of papers in addition of
the Australian historical journal,
which is entirely dedicated
to the Australian Generations
Project in a book.
And the nice thing about the
book is published as an e-book
and I forgot to hit my slide.
Is there more pictures?
Yes, there is.
Zotero, group library, those sorts
of things, and that's the page.
So, the e-book, we could use
our audio delivery system,
cite the content so that
when a person is reading the
book, they click on the link.
It takes them to that place in
the complete five-hour interview
and plays that part but then people
can begin to understand the context
and the relationship of
it to the larger story
and the larger narrative,
and of course,
the larger libraries collection.
I'll stop there.
[ Applause ]
>> Virginia Millington: Great.
So, it's a real pleasure
to be here today.
My name is Virginia Millington.
And I'm the director of Recording
and Archive at StoryCorps.
And one thing that has become
clear to me over the course
of the day is how situated
StoryCorps itself is as a project
within the precedence set by
the American Folklife Center
and in the work that's
being done today.
And just to single out a few
people, the work of Doug Boyd
and Bergis Jules continues to
influence our work and our progress.
Next slide please.
>> Lola Kemp: OK, well,
Seymore [assumed spelling],
I think I'll start and I'll ask you.
>> Seymore Kemp: Well,
you are first.
>> Lola Kemp: All right,
you ask me then.
My-- I'm Lola Kemp [assumed
spelling] and I'm 67 years old
and I'm here with my
husband, Seymore Kemp
and we've been married
for 45 years in March.
>> Seymore Kemp: It's very--
>> Lola Kemp: Now tell
me who you are.
>> Seymore Kemp: My
name is Seymore Kemp
and I'm your husband,
aren't you thrilled?
Anyhow, I was born in
Brunswick, New Jersey.
I live in Highland Park, New Jersey
across the river so
I'm not very far.
And you say, we've been married
45 years and today we decided
to ask questions we probably
never even thought of asking
at all these 45 years,
but these questions will--
maybe will get some
nice answers, who knows?
Anyhow, would you like to begin?
>> Lola Kemp: All right,
I'll start then.
How would you describe
yourself as a child?
Were you happy?
>> Virginia Millington: So
that is a StoryCorps interview
that was recorded within
the first few months
of StoryCorps' beginning in 2003.
And I love that interview or at
least the few seconds we heard
because it really illustrates
key principles essential
to StoryCorps interviews.
Those two participants
knew each other, obviously,
knew each other very well.
And I think that you can hear
the sincerity and the sort
of importance they're placing
on the conversation
they were about to have.
Every StoryCorps interview
was about 40 minutes long
and we have encouraged although
we do not require people
to interview someone that they
know, maybe they love or maybe
as a friend, a colleague
and acquaintance.
And in that way I think that the
model that has been established
within the StoryCorps collection
leads not only to the establishment
of personal narratives,
of conversations
that reflect personal
relationships but also conversations
that reflect broader
social, cultural
and historical events, phases.
And I think that it's that
combination of the personal
and the historical that makes
StoryCorps an interesting
and unique collection and one
that we are happy to place
within the tradition of the
collections described today.
I have a few numbers behind
me which I don't want to dwell
on because those are not
the most important part
of what I'd like to talk about.
But just to give you a sense of the
size of the StoryCorps collection,
at this point, we have
collected over 66,000 interviews
in the last 13 years, that's
over 30,000 hours of audio.
At this point, we have
over a quarter million
participant photographs.
In 2015, we launched the StoryCorps
app which is an opportunity
for anyone with a phone or a tablet
to record StoryCorps interviews
that are also archived at
the Library of Congress.
Since the launch, over 85,000
interviews have been uploaded
to StoryCorps.me, over a
hundred thousand users.
In addition to these interviews,
we have over 700 edited broadcasts.
We have animated shorts and
we have full length books
that contain interviews.
At this point though, one of the
things that we're most interested
in doing is moving beyond
the curated approach
to StoryCorps collections
and thinking about how
to make this amazing collection
which is comprised of interviews
like the one you just heard,
more accessible, more usable
and more helpful to
researchers, scholars,
the general public
and to communities.
One of the things that we're
really excited about is thinking
about this collection that we
have built with the full support
and collaboration of the
American Folklife Center as a site
for research and scholarship
and education.
The slide you see behind me is just
one example of research potential
of the StoryCorps collection.
This is actually a
transcript generated
by MIT's Lincoln Laboratory
in support of a project
that tested a sociolinguistic idea
against computer algorithmic
results.
We've heard from researchers who
are interested in studying all
of our interviews between
teachers and students.
We've heard from researchers that
are interested in studying faith
and belief within the
StoryCorps archive.
And we've also heard from
researchers who were interested
in specific collections, our
9/11 collection and others.
In addition to the
potential for StoryCorps
to not only be a collection of great
importance to researchers, scholars
and others, we believe very,
very strongly that the StoryCorps
collection represents a multitude
of sites of engagement.
Over the course of 13 years,
we've partnered with hundreds
of different community partners
and different organizations
across the country.
And it is our belief that those
partners make the possibility
of the StoryCorps archive a reality.
We don't consider our collection
to be a monolithic collection.
We consider it to be a collection
of multiple relationships
and partnerships.
The two partnerships
I've highlighted here,
the first you can see an exhibition
that use the StoryCorps interviews
that was created to commemorate the
Robert W. Saunders Public Library
in Tampa, Florida.
And the second was a
memory map that was created
by the Oakland China Town
Oral History Project,
in which StoryCorps
interviews were situated
within a Google Map of
important locations.
I'm not sure--
>> My father had a bakery shop, was
the first black bakery in Tampa.
It was called Tasty Bakery Shop.
And I remember I was just
like 4 or 5 years old.
And I remember being-- hanging
out the front door standing
and watching the business, the cars
and the people walking up and down
with those lot entertainment,
entertainers,
that was the chilling circuit of all
the entertainers who come in town.
And they would walk
down the sidewalk.
So you would see the entertainers
during the day and the night.
They would come to my father's
bakery shop and buy pastries,
donuts and twist which he was famous
for, the donuts and the twist.
The twist donuts was the-- that
was the favorite amongst the cakes
and the pies.
But the twist donuts was
one of the favorites.
>> Virginia Millington: So I
use that example which was used
in the exhibition because
I think it displays a--
one thing that I think
is very important
about the StoryCorps collection,
it contains moments so specific
and so local that you can
see how the public that comes
to this exhibition opening would
respond in an almost visceral way
to those memories of food.
And I think that to consider
the StoryCorps collection as one
of intense locality and specificity
but collected on a large scale,
opens up the possibilities and opens
up the possibilities
for collaboration.
We are eager to make the StoryCorps
collection more accessible
and we are grateful to funders
like the National Endowment
for the Humanities for helping
us to do, to achieve this goal.
We believe that by making
this collection accessible,
by allowing for community access and
collaboration with the collection,
we can do more than capture
the stories of communities
and individuals across the country.
We could use them to enhance and
amplify and celebrate the voices
of people all across the country.
So to end, I'm excited to
join this conversation.
And we are excited to work towards
a place where the collection
that we are privileged enough
to hear every day at StoryCorps
and the Library of Congress
can be made accessible
and useful for a broader public.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Nicole Saylor: OK, 30
minutes is just not enough time
to get-- to get too far.
Where to begin?
So can you guys talk about both
of you are doing large
scale collecting work.
What's the primary impact in being
able to collect at this scale
and what is the-- what's the
most challenging aspect to that?
>> Virginia Millington:
I could start.
So, we record-- Can everyone hear
me-- 5000 interviews per year,
through our traditional StoryCorps
methods which include stationeries,
story booths in Chicago,
San Francisco and Atlanta.
Teams of facilitators which I
think really actually hearken back
to the field workers that
we've heard from today.
Teams of facilitators
that go across the country
in an actual Airstream trailer
that cycles the country
recording stories.
We have cataloging systems in place
where our facilitators will tag each
interview, will create log notes
for each interview and will
describe each interview.
So that by the time it comes
to our archive department,
there's enough metadata
to make it describable.
Without that, I think we would face
a lot of challenges in being able
to access the information
within those interviews.
>> Kevin Bradley: We kind of-- We
use a number of [inaudible] machines
which we send around the country.
We have interviewers who are all--
as we said in the talk
are all contracted
to undertake particular work and
we tend to contact them and do it.
And I negotiate the
arrangement with the interviewer.
Materials brought back to us because
I said in broadcast way format,
we ingest that into our
collection management system.
And we create access
points for our interviewers
to create time pointing summaries
which they create as
part of the process.
We ingest all of that into our
collection management system,
create a package that we can then
export that people can use it
and match it up with the
rights document which may--
can then be made available
or not as we go along.
But the-- our Virginia automation is
a necessary part of anything you do.
We have a small number of staff
that facilitate the interviews
and manage miracles and
keeping those things going.
And retaining contacts with
the individuals as well,
as well as providing access to
the collection, whether it's open
because it was [inaudible],
whether it was written permission
or closed for a period of time.
Many of our interviewers could
be closed for the lifetime
of the person, which is
part of the process as well.
We feel that it's-- We'd rather
them talk as long as they like
and tell us things that they
probably don't want out there
and providing the things
that they eventually hoped
to have made available, so.
>> Nicole Saylor: I'm
[inaudible] that you use Zotero.
Could you talk a little bit
about what that is for anybody
who might not know and how that
helps facilitate your work?
>> Kevin Bradley: Zotero we used
in the Generations Project only.
It's not one we generally use.
And we use that because it was a
research project and had a team
of researchers working together
on a single base of material.
So our collection time pointing
system has the capability
to export a package of
the audio and the content.
Now Zotero is a-- It's sort
of like a super EndNote.
You can manage also sorts
of information in it
so that you can annotate
and describe it
and then write your essays and it
all produce all citations for you.
But it also has the ability to
manage group research projects.
So it allow multiple access
to folders and information
and be able to share content.
So what I meant was is when a person
did an interview, they'd come back
and actually the-- in text or in
audio record their impressions
of the process in the interview.
So it's sort of a, you know, they
could put a note there for posterity
that says that was very hard to do
for these reasons or I had a problem
with the next door neighbor's
dog and we had to tie it
up outside or whatever it is.
All those things add a
huge amount of context
to understanding an interview
when you remove from it.
And but they could also go
in, search the time summaries
and annotate points in it as well.
And there were some discussion
this morning about time,
about how you summarize with
those papers and with others.
And that's a-- It's an
interesting process to think
about how you label information,
how you put information in there.
And so we used Zotero for
the researchers to be able
to collaborate and to
be able to work together
to eventually produce a series
of very different chapters
about different topics but using the
same base materials that they did
or as different radio programs
or different other sorts of app
that comes that they produce
as part of the project.
>> Nicole Saylor: You're
talking metadata.
It reminds me of some
conversations Virginia
and I have been having
about metadata.
Do you want to talk any
about contextualizing those?
>> Virginia Millington: Sure.
Well, we-- You know, as a
project that began 13 years ago,
we've certainly evolved
in the dozen or so years
that we've been recording.
And I was actually thinking a lot
about what our collecting practices
will look like in 10 or 20 years.
When we began, we were using a
series of file maker databases,
read-only file maker databases.
We've moved on to a content
management system that's web-based.
We used to provide or we
provide CDs to our participants.
We're now moving to
a digital download.
And in a similar way, our
metadata collection has expanded
and been enhanced.
I think also with the great
support of people like Maggie Kruesi
at the American Folklife
Center, we--
When we began, interestingly enough
we collected demographic information
that was limited to I
believe religion and gender.
And we collected information
about the inter--
each interview that could be boiled
down to one sentence description.
At this point we collected multiple
points of metadata with the belief
that when we make this
collection more accessible
and even now the more
points of access the better.
So at this point we have
interview descriptions.
We have time coded log notes.
We have a set of keywords
that are actually based
on the ethnographic thesaurus.
And we continually update that list.
We are trying-- We are trying
to make our metadata even better
and that's now we're thinking
about ways to embed things
like copyright statements within
our audio files and our photographs.
But it's an evolving process.
We don't have transcripts
for all our interviews
and that's something we've--
we're continually thinking about.
But we do believe that the
points of access we have
at least provide a baseline for
first of all its searchability.
>> Nicole Saylor: Anything
you want to add?
>> Kevin Bradley: Well, we can
start the whole conversation again.
I think it's a very
exciting topic all around.
You stated that that was
so much fun, but let's go.
>> Nicole Saylor: I
was going to say, well,
let's just open it up
for some questions.
We just have a couple of
minutes but let's try.
Does anyone have anything?
[ Inaudible Remark ]
Not that I saw, but I might have.
>> Kevin Bradley: The
mic is coming to you.
Here it is.
>> Nicole Saylor: Sorry, I--
>> Hogging the floor.
>> Nicole Saylor: I saw you.
You're the closest.
>> I was impressed by the
first session this morning
where we were hearing about
social media and the way
in which people want to use social
media resources as a resource
for strategy or research
and of course sometimes
that will be individuals
looking for individual topics.
But there's also there's always
the theme of mass analysis
or data mining or something
like that.
So I'm curios in either of these
oral history projects, is--
do you get signals from
researchers who wish
that somehow they could
data mine the collection
and can you imagine any
way that might happen?
>> Kevin Bradley: Well, yes we do.
Sorry, I jumped in first.
And, yeah, we do quite a bit
and we certainly are engaged
with the digital humanities
community a bit
and discussing the way we do it.
Part of it is the way
we expose our content.
So the stuff that's publicly
available is exposed through trove
which is like the DPLA
Australian version.
So it harvests all the
metadata that's inside the time
pointed summaries.
And you can go-- you can now go
there and download that information.
We have had people do that and
they'll bring that information
and then represent it
in other sorts of ways.
It's limited in that it
would be nice to get--
I would like to be able to allow
searching of the non-expose content,
but not expose the results is
the other part I'd like to do,
which is sort of a complex way
of saying how we can do
the whole collection rather
than just the parts that
are publicly available
without breaching the trust
of the people we have.
But, yeah, it's currently
there for people to do
and people are more
comfortable working
with pictures type approaches to it,
but there has been
some audio approaches
as well representing a data
and otherwise finding content,
mining it for other
sorts of information.
>> It tend to be political history
questions or social theories?
>> Kevin Bradley: Mostly I think
there are people trying to figure
out what they can do with
it more than anything else.
I think the main research is we're
getting the people who are wanting
to use the technology and
seeing how far they can push it.
I think politics will-- those sorts
of things will definitely come next.
>> Did they not talk [inaudible]?
>> Virginia Millington: Yes.
Absolutely.
We've heard from quite
a few researches.
Actually one just on last Friday
who want to use the collection
for large scale data processing.
We hear from people actually
who are very interested
in speech recognition and, you
know, I just want to mention
that while we're so interested in
these inquiries, one of the reasons
that we haven't been able to
fully fulfill this request is
because we're going about making
the collection more accessible again
with the collaboration of
Library of Congress in a way that,
as you just said, respects the
participants' wishes, their intent
and their own perspective
on the interview materials
they've contributed.
So, I fully imagine in a
few years or even later
than that our collection
will be used
for large scale research request.
But at this point we're only hearing
about those requests not being
able to act on them too much.
>> Nicole Saylor: Sadly, I'm going
to have to leave it right there.
It was-- We hardly got started but--
>> Kevin Bradley: I had
questions for Virginia.
>> Nicole Saylor: Did you--
Do you-- Well, I mean--
>> Kevin Bradley: We'll do it later.
>> Nicole Saylor: I encourage you
all to catch them on the break.
So, thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Steve Winick: So our next
collection feature is going to be
about the Sidney Robertson
Cowell Collection here
in the American Folklife
Center Archive.
And there's no better person
to introduce that collection
than my colleague Cathy Kerst.
And I've been privileged to work
with Cathy Kerst now for 11 years
and she is the source of knowledge
on the Sidney Robertson Cowell
Collection among many other things.
She is a folklorist and she's
a cataloger and she's been
with the AFC for a long time.
And in fact, she has
quite recently retired.
She's the most recent
person to retire
from our staff and we miss her.
But the nice thing is that she is
volunteering and coming back to work
on the Sydney Robertson Cowell
Collection and she's working
on a book based on this collection.
So, Cathy Kerst is
going to tell us now
about the Sidney Robertson
Cowell Collection.
>> Catherine Kerst: Thank you Steve.
Lady on Wheels.
In a draft of an undated manuscript
entitled "Lady on Wheels" written
by Sidney Robertson Cowell probably
in the 1950s, she drafted a proposal
for a series of programs,
as she put it,
about the life of a lady on wheels.
She explained, "Most of you
know that my chief preoccupation
for a long time has been the
quote 'Music that's gifted to us',
as an old lady in North Carolina
once defined folk music to me."
Robertson traveled
thousands of miles in her car,
accompanied by her dog, collecting
traditional music and song
from the 1930s into the 1950s.
In the "Lady on Wheels" proposal
she wrote, "Folksong is song alive.
It seems to me that folk song has
gone on living only where new ways
and new uses for it could give
it freshness and vitality."
Throughout her ethnomusicological
research, Robertson had no use
for song as remnant or survival.
It was living song
that she was after.
And luckily for us here at
the Library of Congress,
she left her perceptive
and colorful descriptions
of the music she recorded and
the performers who sang for her
in ample field notes,
correspondences--
correspondence and reminiscences
both in the music division
at the library here and the
American Folklife Center.
Robertson was born Sidney William
Hawkins in 1903 in San Francisco.
Precocious, curious and
gregarious from an early age.
She graduated in Romance
languages from Stanford,
studied music in Paris, and attended
Jung seminars in Zurich and London.
By the late 1920s, Robertson was
back in California teaching music
at the progressive Peninsula
School in Menlo Park,
and excited to be attending
lectures on world music
at the San Francisco
Conservatory given
by composers Ernest
Bloch and Henry Cowell.
Here I will refer to
her as Robertson,
the name she acquired
from her first marriage.
Later, after the California project
and her marriage to Henry Cowell,
she was called Sidney
Robertson Cowell.
Here's a picture taken
in 1929 when she was
in her 30s-- in her 20s, excuse me.
In 1936, while visiting
friends in Washington,
Robertson met Charles Seeger,
then in charge of the music unit
at the Resettlement Administration.
She soon became his
assistant and also proficient
at making instantaneous
disc recordings.
As she put it, "I got
hooked on the work
and the wonderful hopeful
and dedicated new deal.
So when Charlie asked me to
stay on, I couldn't resist."
With Resettlement and then the
Farm Security Administration,
Robertson traveled thousands of
miles on her own making hundreds
of recordings of traditional
music throughout the south,
the Ozarks and into the Midwest.
When funds from Washington for
further recording dried up,
she gave her remaining contacts
to Alan Lomax for his later forays
into Croatian, Finnish, and other
communities in the Upper Midwest
and she returned to San Francisco.
There she hoped to create a survey
of northern California folk music
on her own by recording
English language
and what she called minority
immigrant groups supported
through the WPA, the Works
Project Administration.
Without giving much background here
on the complicated process
it entailed, let me just say
that she was successful and
it was quite an achievement.
Robertson was 33, energetic,
outgoing and eager
to record what people were singing
wherever and whenever she could.
She secured co-sponsorship for
the project from the Library
of Congress, which among other
things sent blank acetate discs
for making recordings.
And from the University
of California Berkeley,
she was provided an
office on Shattuck Avenue
for 20 workers she handpicked
from the California relief rolls
and were required by the WPA.
Once the project opened, Robertson
supervised the staff during the day
and in the evenings and on the
weekend she took her baby portable
presto recording machine as she
called it, new on the market
at that time, out and about to
make recordings wherever she could.
Here she is making copies
for the Library of Congress
of the recordings that were made.
So from October 1938 through early
1940, Robertson recorded 35 hours
of music from numerous California
performers on the project.
WPA staff took photos and made
technical drawings of many
of the musical instruments.
She hoped that her project
would become a prototype
for the collection of folk
music across the country,
something that had
never been done before,
especially with the inclusion of
the music of recent immigrants.
It is really hard to describe
the breadth of genres recorded
from so many cultural
groups in 10 minutes.
Two thirds of the recording were
what she called minority groups.
She was sensitive as we are
now about the word foreign.
She-- So she called the minority
groups Armenians, Basques, Finns,
and you see this quite
impressive list.
Then one third of the collection
was English-language material.
And she even went so far as to call
some of the migrants from Wisconsin
in the Upper Midwest immigrants to
sort of level the playing ground
of what she was recording.
She was very aware of this.
In the September 1938 San Francisco
Chronicle article, Robertson wrote
about California's
rich cultural heritage,
including the Native
Americans, the early Spanish
and Portuguese arrivals,
and the discovery of gold
which brought settlers from five
continents and the seven seas.
How can we believe that
these successive waves
of hardworking citizens
contributed nothing
to California beyond
the work of their hands?
What traditions came with them?
What were they thinking and
feeling as they labored in mines
and forests, herding cattle and
sheep along the slopes, plowing
and harvesting in the valleys
and fishing along our coasts?
Their songs will tell
us if we can find them.
How does one find songs, she asked.
They are everywhere at hand.
A man changing a tire
on Shattuck Avenue
in Berkeley last month sang an old
ballad as he worked and was startled
by an urgent request to repeat
it so it could be written down.
A receipt for a bill for a rail--
paid to a railway express
deliveryman was signed
with a Basque name.
This led to a whole nest of songs.
And one man in Chester County
offered to outsing the gas tank
if he might ride along to Fresno.
My thought is to give you a
teeny taste of the recordings.
These two recordings, if I
can fit them in, are portions,
feature songs about
the homeland that many
of the immigrants left behind
central to the story of migration.
This is Rouben Baboian.
Robertson attended all sorts
of events of the Armenians,
visited their coffee shops and she
was entranced by the lively variety
of music making she
found in the community.
Her field reports tell that Mr.
Baboian was an unusually fine singer
who had learned all
his songs as a boy
in the Armenian mountains near
Van, currently in Eastern Turkey.
The role of folk singer
was traditionally
in his father's family, she wrote.
And he learned these songs
in the pure Armenian style,
free of any Turkish taint.
Andouni is an Armenian folk song
often translated as the homeless.
Following the First World War and
the Armenian genocide in 1915,
that included massacres
and deportations near
Baboian's original home.
And this song has become
emblematic of the losses experienced
by Armenians and continues to
hold great symbolic meaning
for those in the diaspora.
[ Singing ]
Next slide, please.
Elinor Rodriguez was one of
three women from Puerto Rico
who sang children songs and games,
Christmas songs or aguinaldos
and other popular tunes
for Robertson in Oakland
where many Puerto Ricans migrated.
And Elinor Rodriguez's
version of "Lamento Borincano",
a sense of heartfelt
emotion and deep longing
for Puerto Rico infused her
singing although her pronunciation
and articulation reflect the fact
that she was a second
generation Puerto Rican.
[ Singing ]
OK.
This popular bolero
was and continues
to be a heartfelt song among Puerto
Ricans with his nostalgic imagery
and sense of longing
for the homeland.
So this has been a mere
glimpse of the valuable
and expensive California folk
music project collection organized
and carried out single handedly
by a remarkable, ambitious
and open-minded collector
in only 17 months
in California during the new deal.
There is much, much more
about this collection
that I have absolutely no time
to talk about with you today
but you can find most of
the collection online here
at the library on the California
Gold site including the photographs,
the scale drawings,
the field reports,
and all sorts of other things.
It will be migrated to Project One
soon so I don't know if it will look
like this in the future, but
there's a lot to be discovered.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Todd Harvey: We have this.
Good. Mics are alive.
My name is Todd Harvey.
I'm a curator at the
American Folklife Center.
I'm proud to be a member of the
American Folklife Center staff,
an organization that can bring
together a group like this
for a whole day and keep
them in their seats.
It's pretty amazing.
And I hope to continue to--
continue the discussion.
The discussion to me has been
about collections and about access.
And that's, of course, the two kind
of central tenets of
working in archives.
You have to gather the
materials and preserve them
and you have to create access.
And we work with that every day.
In 1932 or so, the Archive of
American Folk Song, as it was called
at the time, consisted of about
900 wax cylinder recordings.
This year, we're going to accession
among other things Virginia's 85,000
plus oral histories
with StoryCorps.me.
So, there's a slight
shift in scale with that.
And with that comes access, right?
And in 1932, there was
no access to the archive.
This is the first point of
access that we had as an archive.
And it's a 1934 publication,
the reading room's copy
of "American Ballads and Folk
Songs" by John Lomax and Alan Lomax
which contains among other
things transcriptions of some
of the recordings that they had made
or that they had themselves
transcribed in the field.
They, you know, according to my
research there was no way for anyone
to listen to any of those discs
if even they were at the archive.
I think most of them were still
on the Lomax's possession.
And so from this publication,
the paper publication, again,
we have StoryCorps.me, which
is a brand new collection
and there's instantaneous
access to that thing.
So, we'll be talking about
different ways to access
and different approaches to access
to the material in our archives.
And we've assembled a panel
of notables that I would
like to introduce to you.
Next to me is Lance Ledbetter.
He is the-- He and his wife April
are-- does the digital records.
And Lance, who's been a great friend
to the archive in publishing some
of our materials and
we hope to cultivate
that wonderful relationship
long into the future.
Kelly Navies is from the
Smithsonian National Museum
of African-American
History and Culture.
You just have to say the new museum
and everyone knows what
you're talking about there.
I can't imagine how we got her away
from there so close to the opening.
>> Kelly Navies: It wasn't easy.
>> Todd Harvey: But she's
here for a good reason
and that is per Congress's
mandate we have worked with that,
that museum to create the Civil
Rights Oral History Project.
And Kelly has been integral to it
as has John Bishop,
the man next to her.
John was the-- is a filmmaker
and they let him out for the day
from Los Angeles to
come and sit with us.
And he was the-- He's the
man behind the camera.
If you go to those oral
histories which are online
through the American Folklife
Center website, you'll see his work.
And John has deep, deep roots
with the American Folklife
Center going back to his work
with Alan Lomax on "Land
Where the Blues Began"
and a number of other projects.
And then furthest away, Gabriela
Perez Baez from the National--
Smithsonian National
Museum of Natural History.
One of the great assets in our
collections are the recordings
of native peoples of North America
and South America and
Central America.
And one project to bring those
out into the world is
called Breath of Life.
And I hope that you'll
talk about that.
And I wonder if we'll-- We
should just start at that far end
and work our way this direction.
And I'll turn it over.
>> Gabriela Perez Baez: Thank you.
And so this is-- very good.
OK. Well, thank you all for coming.
I am the curator of linguistics
at the National Museum
of Natural History in the
Anthropology Department.
And I'm also the director
of Recovering Voices.
And I'd like to talk to you a
little bit about Recovering Voices
and I'll finish with-- in to talk--
talking about the Breath of Life
Institute which is a big focus
of our work in Recovering Voices.
Sorry, I'm having to use
my two hands to navigate.
It's a little confusing but--
So, the Recovering Voices as we'd
like to call it a response from
the Smithsonian Institution
to the language endangerment
and knowledge--
endangerment of knowledge
systems crisis around the world.
So, the 6 or 7000 languages
spoken around the world,
it's known that at least a third,
if not more, are in the process
of being replaced by the other
more dominant languages whether
regionally or internationally
and it could--
The forecast suggest
that as many as 90%
of these languages could potentially
go silent by the end of the century.
So, what can the museum do?
We have articulated an approach
based on research, on languages
and knowledge systems to understand
the loss of cultural diversity
and develop effective
responses to reverse it.
This is based on access
to collections.
So, this access is central to
the recovery and generation
of knowledge in the process.
And global impact is
achieved through partnerships
with communities and
academic institutions,
one of them being the
Library of Congress.
What distinctive competence
do we offer?
Among many assets at the museum,
we have the National
Anthropological Archives.
And also within the many assets
at the NAA are 9000 linear feet
of manuscript dating back to the--
the bulk dates back to the 1800s
but we have manuscripts
that go back to the 1600s
from everywhere around the world.
In addition, we have a very
extensive collection of film
at the Human Studies Film Archives,
as well as photographs and artwork.
In-- Outside the archives
in our collections,
we have over 126 million objects,
and that means natural specimens.
It means mineral samples.
It means ethnographic
material culture collections.
So, the point is to
capitalize on these collections
and on the intellectual capital
of the institution to be able
to put these strengths
to the services
of community based
researchers who are looking
to revitalize their languages,
their knowledge systems or cultures.
We have two programmatic and we
have several programmatic activities
but two of them that I want to focus
on today are the Community Research
Program and the National Breath
of Life Archival Institute
for Indigenous Languages.
I'll just say National
Breath of Life for short.
Community Research
Program, this is a program
through which we fund
a visit to our museum
or our institution collections,
not exclusively the museum,
for community research who have us--
of an articulated project
for revitalization
of language, of knowledge
or culture.
And so we will fund up to $10,000
in travel expenses for a group,
preferably intergenerational,
preferably interdisciplinary,
but not tied to any specific
academic credentials to come
and carry out research
in collections, again,
at the National Museum of Natural
History or NMAI or any other unit
in the Smithsonian
although it tends to--
the research tends to
focus on the collections
of the these two museums.
And National Breath of Life,
the National Breath of Life,
it follows the model of the
California Breath of Life
which began in the 1990s and
takes place every two years.
And it's some-- it's a training
program to provide capacity.
It's a capacity build of--
program to train researchers from
communities on research on archives
and research in linguistics for the
purposes of language reclamation.
At the origin in California,
the focus was on tribes
who no longer had first
language speakers.
This later expanded and
two institutes were held
in Oklahoma at the Sam Noble Museum.
We have held three National
Breath of Life Institutes
and we now have funding secured
from the National Science Foundation
Documenting Endangered Languages
program to hold the 2017 institute
May 29 to June 9th of next year.
So, the point is to
bring researchers to DC
so that they can have access
to the unparalleled collections
at the National Museum
of Natural History,
notably the Anthropological
Archives, the National Museum
of the American-Indian and
the Library of Congress.
The objective is to familiarize
participants with the holdings
at these institutions, teach
fundamentals of linguistics
so that they can begin to read
and interpret the materials.
So, for this purpose each
participant gets paired
up with an academically
trained linguist.
And from day one they work on the
analysis of manuscripts on languages
that they're interested in.
They discuss and demonstrate ways
that materials can be utilized
for purposes of language
revitalization and learning
and provide optional short
sessions on computer technology,
dictionary development, song
writing, writing systems, et cetera.
We are-- We have now worked
with over 50 languages
and we'll add another
14 or 15 in 2017.
It has been critical to
partner with the Library
of Congress especially
given our joint history tied
to the Federal Cylinder Project.
So, the materials here,
the songs are--
the prayers are really
critical to these researchers.
These researchers get very
technical linguistics training
so that they can decide
for so to speak some
of the language documentation
produce by linguists.
But they're really, really
more interested in being able
to regain cultural knowledge
that is in these collections.
And in that respect, the Library of
Congress collection is essential.
Thank you.
>> Todd Harvey: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Mr. Bishop.
>> John Bishop: Well, I'm
not sure why I'm on the panel
because mostly I should film and
edit film and produce things.
But as a freelance
camera person I'm often--
I'm involved in large scale
doc-- we call documentation.
I work with the Dance
Department at UCLA and, you know,
did films on Hawaiian dance, did
several projects on Cambodian dance.
And one thing that
I realized in make--
in shooting documentation is
that people don't really
want to be documented.
They want to be loved.
And it's in a-- Say it's a--
Actually it sounds like a joke
but it's very, very true.
They're engaging with
you when you're shooting.
It can be a dance.
They're not going to
show you the steps,
they're going to dance for you.
On people when we do the civil
rights oral history interviews,
we're not just getting a story told.
They are performing
the story for us.
And the resulting tape is
a glimpse into that moment
when this information was shared.
There's a lot more valence to it
than just what can be
abstracted from the words.
And I just wanted to mention that
as something that should be kept
in mind that it's very
easy when you're--
what it used to be now with the--
now I just use my cellphone.
But in the olden days when
you were on photographing
with like they're doing in the back,
it's easy to get lost up and swept
up in your technology,
you know, your craft.
And in the kind of work we all
do, it's much more important
to nail the craft before you go out.
Know how to get it into focus,
make a nice composition.
And then you're engaged--
You as a crafts person,
you're actually engaged in a
communication with the person.
On the oral history
interviews, we'd-- We have--
usually just myself
and the oral historian.
And it's a relationship
in those two hours.
Another point I'd like to make about
shooting for documentary projects is
that really helps to visualize
how the material will be used.
I'd say on my darkest days I see
it going into a lead lined box deep
in a pyramid in the desert.
And other times though
like I see the--
like I can see it being used
a little bit of stock footage.
Someone might want to pull material
that we shoot for essentially
to document aspects of craft or
aspects of performance or history.
I can visualize it on being used--
being edited, being presented either
in short pieces or what way with
the civil rights oral histories.
I go crazy by about the third
interview in the sequence
because I'm editing it in my mind.
Oh, so and so said that.
That goes along with what
someone else was saying.
Because in this case,
we're building a tapestry,
the documentation is
building an enormous tapestry
of a huge historical event.
The other point I'd
like to make is just
to give a hundred thousand
props to the Library of Congress
for putting the first hundred and--
I guess 120 oral histories actually
up on the web with the transcripts.
So anyone can access it live
and they can feel what
people are saying.
They can read the transcript and
get into abstract information
or to find where they are.
This is something that's now
technologically possible.
And this is the first time I've
been involved in something that--
thanks to Guha Shankar who actually
done-- and actually makes it happen.
First time in my life that that
material I haven't had to wait
for a year or two or whatever
before things can circulate or--
And these enterprises we are
engaged in or done at great expense,
great financial expense
and great personal expense.
There's a lot of effort
that goes into it.
And it's extremely gratifying
to see it actually being seen.
So I'll let someone else
have that minute and a half.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
>> Kelly Navies: Good afternoon.
My name is Kelly Navies.
I'm the museum specialist
oral historian
at the Smithsonian National Museum
of African-American
History and Culture.
I would like to thank the Library of
Congress for inviting me here today.
We are as you know very busy.
But I'm very happy
to be on this panel,
and I'm glad that you're here, Mr.
Bishop, because I never met you.
This is my first time meeting you.
I'm relatively new so I
actually wasn't there for all
of the interviews that he's
talking about but I'm going
to share a little bit
more about that project.
The oral history program at
the Smithsonian National Museum
of African-American
History and Culture is
as you know a new and
evolving program.
Our goal is to produce and
collect oral history content
for our growing collection.
In addition, we are committed to
making this material accessible
and usable to our many
publics, general, scholars,
researchers, teachers and students.
These various constituency
should be able
to access oral history
materials not just recordings
but associated documentation
both online
and by coming into the museum.
In addition, our collection is
intended to support the work
and research of our curators
as they develop exhibitions.
In the years prior to our
opening and prior to my joining
with the program, we began
to collect oral histories
through our collaboration
with the Library of Congress
on the civil rights
oral history project.
And you've been hearing
a little bit about that.
The civil rights history
project began in 2009
when the US Congress passed the
Civil Rights History Project Act.
This law directed the Library of
Congress and the National Museum
of African-American
History and Culture
to conduct a nationwide survey of
existing oral history collections
with relevance to the civil
rights history movement,
and to record new interviews
with people
who participated in the movement.
There have been approximately
144 interviews conducted
and recorded on film.
Some of these interviews are
with well know movement icons,
but many others are with
less known individuals
who played important
roles in the movement.
The significance of these
interviews is immense.
Their content reveals the work
and day-to-day experiences
of major players not
just in the south
but throughout the United States.
For example, the most recent
cohort of interviews were done
in Southern California
with former members
of the Black Panther Party
and the Brown Berets.
One of my favorite interviews
is with Freeman Hrabowski.
Dr. Hrabowski is known mostly
in academic circles for his work
as the president of the University
of Maryland, Baltimore County
where he has developed a highly
successful math and science program
that targets those
who are historically
represented in those fields.
What is less known is his
role in the Children's Crusade
of Birmingham, Alabama and the
fact that he was actually friends
with the four girls who
were killed in the bombing
at the 16th Street
Baptist Church in 1963.
During his interview
with Dr. Joe Mosnier
of the Southern Oral History
Program at UNC Chapel Hill
where I'm also from, by the way.
Dr. Hrabowski gives a poignant
and moving telling of this chapter
in his life and the
life of our nation.
In story, one is struck by
the trajectory of his life
from the upheaval and
trauma of those early years
to his contemporary role
as a committed activist
in the sphere of academics.
What this and other
oral history interviews
from this collection reveal
is that beyond the retelling
of historical events, oral
histories have the power to inspire
and trigger the much
needed healing process.
As a nation we are still grappling
with the trauma of racial violence
and it is one of the goals
of the National Museum
of African-American History and
Culture to be a place of healing
as well as a place of learning.
With the availability
of this collection,
a visitor can view the display of
Emmett Till's coffin, and then go
and listen to the reflections
of those like the Ladner sisters
who were directly impacted
by Till's murder in 1955.
Another strength of the civil rights
history project is the diversity
it portrays.
In addition to the
integration of the well known
with the less celebrated, it also
showcases stories of non-black
such as Luis Zapata, a
Latino-American who grew
up in Orange County,
California and became active
in the United Farm Workers.
And then moved to Mississippi
to become active in both SNCC
and the Mississippi
Freedom Labor Union.
Then there's the story of
David and Satoko Ackerman,
an interracial couple,
Caucasian and Japanese,
who met at the Chicago Theological
Seminary and were then recruited
by fellow student Jesse
Jackson to join the march
from Selma to Montgomery.
There are also many interviews
with the women of the movement
like Dr. Kathleen Cleaver
of the Black Panther Party,
and sisters Joyce and Dorie Ladner
who have led lifetimes of activism
through involvement
in the NAACP, SNCC,
and in many other campaigns
for justice.
The cultural and gender
diversity displayed
in these interviewees provides
a more complete picture
of what we call the movement
and it reaches our understanding
of the contextual experience
of those we call activist.
What motivates them?
What are their lives like
on a day-to-day basis?
There are also interviews
with siblings
and whole families would
shed light on the ways
in which the civil rights movement
impacted not just individuals
but social networks
and entire communities.
I've already used this collection
to introduce foreign students
to our oral history collection.
Students from Southeast
Asia were very interested
in how oral history enables one
to capture stories of trauma
and oppression and
were anxious to go home
and record their own stories, as
well as interview their relatives.
One of the reasons I am so
passionate about oral history is
that there are so many
layers of meaning
and so many ways of
using the material.
I look forward to presenting
oral history to our many publics
through exhibits and
variety of programs
and through training and workshops.
The civil rights history project
is a good model for the kind
of oral history work we
plan to do, collaborations
with other institutions that
produce rich oral histories
that have multifaceted
meanings and applications.
Most recently, I have been
directing an oral history project
with individuals who
donated significant items
and artifacts to our collection.
As a museum, our oral history
collection is deeply connected
to the material collection.
There are interviews
with artifact donors
that reveal not just the
provenance of particular pieces
but also the relationship of
these items to the lives of those
who once possessed them
and how these stories fit
into the larger narrative
of African-American
history and culture.
Yeah, I'll take questions later.
OK. Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Lance Ledbetter: Hi, I'm Lance
Ledbetter from Dust-to-Digital.
As Todd was saying, we
are a record company.
My-- It's just my wife and myself
and we're based in Atlanta, Georgia.
I think a record company like ours,
there's not really a
roadmap for what we do.
We've sort of evolved over time
but I want to walk through today
and kind of tell the story
about how we got to work
with such great archive as
the Library of Congress,
the Florida Folklife Program,
the Center for Southern Folklife,
the Association for Cultural
Equity and the University
of Georgia Archives among others.
Our label started in
2003 with the release
of a box set called
"Goodbye, Babylon".
And what we were trying to do
with that set was, you know,
it's all gospel music
recorded between 1902 to 1960.
But what we're trying to do is
provide access point to this sort
of overwhelming amount of
content by showing like subgenres
of the different styles
of gospel music.
We worked with musicologists like
Dick Spottswood, Charles Wolfe
and Tony Russell to produce a
set that sort of told the story
of gospel music while making
various objective selections
to get people an access point.
During the four and a half years to
produce "Goodbye, Babylon" we sort
of set the standards, aesthetic
standards and mission of our label.
We decided we want to produce
high quality cultural artifacts.
And what I mean by that is we want
to have topnotch documentation
with beautiful packaging
and terrific design.
We thought that the music was so
important we want to elevate it to,
you know, to this thing
that was beautiful
where people will hopefully
pay attention.
And that was back in '03
when there's a lot less
distractions than there are now.
In 2004, Art Rosenbaum and I met.
And Art Rosenbaum,
for those of the--
for those of you that don't know, he
made field recordings for probably
about 40 years in their house at
the University of Georgia Archives
where Art was a professor.
Art and I had several conversations.
He was a fan of "Goodbye,
Babylon" and we talked
about possibly doing something
similar, like a similar model
for his field recordings.
So Art and I spent about a year
and a half just listening to all
of his recordings and it was just--
it was a great, great experience
to do that with somebody as
incredible as Art Rosenbaum.
And the set we produced
was called "Art
of Field Recording"
that came out in 2008.
It was well received and it was
our first work with an archive.
It was with the University
of Georgia Archive.
Before that time, we
were only working
with private record collectors.
Like I said, the set
was well received,
actually, even won a Grammy Award.
And we were so excited but at
the same time my wife and I,
although it was a terrific
experience, we realized, you know,
to take a year and a half to listen
to audio and still be a, you know,
functioning recording company
and putting out records,
we needed to refine that
process a little bit.
So we did.
You know, we started to
hear from other archives.
You know, I think the "Art of
Field Recording" set sort of put us
on the archival map with people
that had lots of great material.
The next set that we did with
an archive was the "Drop on Down
in Florida" set which was a--
it was a reissue of a double LP
that the Florida State Folklife
Program have put out in the 1980s
and they want to do like
an expanded edition.
So we kept their original notes.
We expand the liner notes and we
expand the audio to be two CDs.
It's almost like double the audio
material as the original double LP.
But in doing so, we worked
a lot with the archive.
We let them develop a lot of the--
make a lot of the decisions
in the development stages.
What we sort of shifted our
expertise to was more in the--
helping them with the concepts,
the packaging and the design,
the marketing, the
manufacturing and the distribution.
And that set was well received too.
We didn't win a Grammy but
it was very well received.
And it came together very well
and it sort of tested this sort
of new approach for us to where
we can work with an archive
and have them using their
expertise in their field
and us using our expertise
in our field.
So since then we've worked
with several more archives
including the Library of Congress.
We worked with Jim Leary at the
University of Wisconsin to do a set
of folk songs from another America.
And we-- That was a partnership
with the University Press,
the University of Wisconsin Press.
And since then we've done another
Library of Congress project.
We did the-- It was sort of similar
to the "Drop on Down in Florida"
where it was originally put out as
a three LP set in the '70s "Music
of Morocco" which was
recorded by Paul Bowles.
And that set that came out earlier
this year has been probably one
of our best received
projects and in several years.
So, you know, I want to just
kind of say how, you know,
what our process is, how we've
evolved to work with more archives.
And I think what we, you know,
as a label bring to the--
to this, you know, the sharing
is with a physical package,
you have a beginning
and you have an end.
And you can direct people, you
know, to the infinite archive.
The online material, you know,
that's something that we can help,
you know, raise awareness of what
archives have in the context of,
you know, consumerism and record
nerds and, you know, all that stuff.
And we get those people to
appreciate and come to learn
about all the great
work that archives
like the Library of Congress does.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Todd Harvey: I wonder if we
can go straight to questions.
This is some fast meeting folks.
>> John Bishop: Can I
ask the first question?
>> Todd Harvey: Yeah.
>> John Bishop: I just wanted
to comment on Freeman Hrabowski.
He was one of the more
intense interviews.
And the story that when
he told about the girls
in Birmingham he was
crying, I was crying.
I'm really good at staying
in focus when I'm crying.
And we had to pause and he said
that he hadn't told that story
in 30 years, but it was the
attention we were paying to him.
It is literally that he would-- that
he felt moved just to tell it and--
what he'd not intended to.
>> Kelly Navies: That's
a very powerful segment
and you edited it quite
well, so yes.
>> Todd Harvey: Hey, Mary.
>> Mary: I wanted to just
say how much I appreciate--
Well, it's a wonderful,
wonderful session of course.
Thank you for putting it together.
I wanted to just say to John
Bishop how much I appreciate--
You're bringing out the
recording and the photograph
as really an artifact
of the relationship
between the photographer, the
field worker, and the person.
And I-- Yeah, I don't think we
paid enough attention to that
in our session this morning
because we were almost--
We were on the verge of getting
there but didn't get there.
And I just love the way
that you've drawn that out.
Do you-- So what do you-- So where
does that go when you're looking
at these decontextualized artifacts?
Can you as a photographer
read those--
>> John Bishop: Well,
I can see that--
>> Mary: -- as a way-- I mean
and Anne Hoag [assumed spelling],
actually she anticipated.
She said, look and
look at these pictures.
You can see that there
is a relationship
between the photographer
and the subject.
Can you talk about that?
>> John Bishop: Well, I could
see it in the photographs
that you showed in
your presentation.
What do you about it or?
>> Mary: Well, you just say
something more about that.
Yeah.
>> John Bishop: Well, it's--
There's a leap that you have to make
between the tech-- with what you're
doing technically and aesthetically.
And you-- I don't consider
myself an artist.
I'm, you know, its-- that's
I'm not there to make art.
But I feel an obligation
when I take people's time
to do something with it.
And often it comes in a
compulsion to edit what I've shot
after an interval of time goes by.
I remember that something they said
or some beautiful movement they did
or something and feel that
I have to make the film just
to get these three
things in and, you know,
that there is that
sort of post thing.
Otherwise, you know,
it's just-- and like I--
people seem to tolerate
me pretty well, so.
But I think that's part of the--
What happened in your case as well
that people like you and
you got along with them.
>> Todd Harvey: Someone this
morning used the term shoulder
to shoulder as in fieldwork.
But in a sense we're expanding
that to be inter-institutional
or across professionalize
with these folks
because they are providing
access to our collections.
And John didn't mention
media generation.
His-- the distribution
aspect of his creative work,
which is in a way similar
to Dust-to-Digital
in that they are providing
great access
and beautiful access
to archival material.
>> So is there [inaudible]
competitors.
>> Todd Harvey: No, no.
No.
[ Laughter ]
>> Well, and Mary's question
and John's remarks, you know,
make me think, help me out.
Am I remembering the
term reflexivity?
Is that one of those
words that we hear in--
>> Kelly Navies: Yeah.
>> -- hotdog.
I think a characteristic of what
you're talking about and what we did
in fact to see in the pictures this
morning has to do with a willingness
and a consciousness of the
importance of reflexivity
in the work of documentation
that we did.
And what it gives you
at least to not--
in those pictures that
we saw because the team
in a sense gave a meta-documenter
of the documentary act, and in--
as was said in enriched
contextual thing
that lets you understand
the document quo document,
if you see what I mean, because
you not only have the document,
you also sort of have the
sense of how it was made.
But it's also a reflexive process.
I mean, I remember I
worked on that book
of bluegrass photos,
it was Neil Rosenberg.
And the text is threaded through
with how the two of us drove hither
and thither and ran into people.
So we're a part of the
story and, you know,
there may be egotism involved
that I think it was also,
you know, to contextualize it.
But this is a sort of thing
you're really good at.
So what do you think?
>> Mary: No, again--
>> The reflexivity.
>> Mary: Well, I don't know.
Well, I wasn't quite thinking of
it so much as although-- Yeah.
I mean I think of reflexivity as
this sort of two-headed aspect
that you have to have when
you're doing ethnography.
You have to be able to--
as you said, the metadata.
But you have to be able to be--
to move very rapidly between
being absorbed in the interaction
and standing back and
giving it a label, metadata.
This is, you know,
here's what we're doing
and here's what I'm going
to ask next or whatever.
But this whole business of
the photograph reflect--
Well, reflecting, reflexivity.
Reflecting something of the
relationship that is going on.
I think that that's
something that the big moment.
I remember Alan one
time saying that they--
The great insight of the
20th century was context.
And that context, you know, across
the philosophies and at the--
in sciences and so forth that.
And so we shifted.
Around the time that the
American Folklife Center
and the legislation was passed,
we shifted from this idea of--
from this practice of
collecting nuggets.
That, yeah, text and
images and so forth.
And to actually going off
in search of those moments
of what Dell Hymes has
called breakthrough
into performance where--
and then turning that.
So that these things in the
archives are potentially very
living documents.
I mean the-- What happens
to those relationships?
I think of that-- it as the--
what [inaudible] called
the difference between--
the difference is not between
body and soul or matter and mind
but between flesh fallen
and flesh transfigured.
And the transfigurement
is in the relationship.
And you take that--
You just take the--
You take the document
or whatever and it's
like what Barry Tolchin [assumed
spelling] said is a footprint,
you know, of an interaction.
Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
>> Hey.
>> Todd Harvey: Over here.
Wow.
>> Hi, I just wanted to comment to
Gabriela that I appreciate the work
that you do among many others for
Recovering Voices and Breath of Life
because I think it's a
really wonderful example
of how these amazing institutions
that physically are located
in DC can give back to
communities all over the world,
especially indigenous communities.
And I was hoping you could talk
about some sort of concrete examples
of what you saw people
take home with them.
What did they take with them
to their communities even
though it lives in the archives?
How are those relationships
expanding?
>> Gabriela Perez Baez:
Good question.
So, OK. So we've done
Breath of Life three times.
And I think I would
say that what they take
with them is a lot of excitement.
What ends up happening is that
our holdings are so extensive
that two weeks of intensive training
in linguistics, intensive training
into what the archives hold, it
ends up being super overwhelming
in a good way and they live and
they're very excited to know
that all of this material has exist
and it's a resource for them to use.
Now what we're trying to do now
because one thing that we're not--
don't have a good handle on is
what happens after they leave.
And so for example
we have experiences
with the [inaudible],
the Barbareno Chumash.
And with the Seneca groups
where they left knowing--
when they were here for Breath of
Life they had developed an inventory
of all the materials that they
had and we were able to take
that inventory and
we had an opportunity
to digitize the materials.
I should mention that
when-- with Breath of Life,
we digitize a selection of materials
so that the participants
have something
to work on right of the bat.
They won, they have a digital
surrogate that they can work on.
And we choose that very carefully
depending on the vitality
of the language, the experience
that the person might have
in doing linguistic research
or not and we select something
that they can start
working on right away.
We also have post institute
digitization funds.
So if they discovered something
that they really want,
we can digitize it.
But generally the collections
tend to be very extensive
and they go away knowing
that there's boxes and boxes,
especially when it comes to
languages and cultures documented
in the Harrington Collection
for example.
It's just massive what
they might have.
So anyway in the case of the
Seneca and the Chumash groups,
we were able to do follow
up in two different ways.
So the Seneca developed an
inventory of all the materials.
We happen to have a
digitization grant.
So we were able to digitize
the entire collection
of Seneca materials and
return that to them to--
at no charge to the
community, to the researchers.
So now they have all this wealth.
They're so overwhelmed but
they have the stuff with them
and they can start digging through
and I'll go back to that point.
The-- with the Barbareno Chumash,
they knew that there was a lot
of stuff because this is one
of the languages documented
in the Harrington Collection.
So they came back.
They came to Breath of
Life, they worked on that
for two weeks then they applied
for a community research
program opportunity.
And they came back for a
week and I worked with them
that whole week specifically
to develop an inventory
that they could use to
develop their notation
so that they could always
go back to the document
of where they could find
the particular word.
So for the Barbareno Chumash,
they have been reconstructing
for example their-- or they were
working on their numeral system
and they had found number 24,
number 26 which allow them to--
which provided an important clue
as to how the numeral
system was constructed.
So-- But they needed to be able
to pinpoint that one page in--
amidst the thousands of
pages where that word is.
So this was a rudimentary
way to do it.
Now with those two experiences, we--
I'm working with our partner
which is someone who I neglected
to mention but who's a
critical partner in this
and they were Daryl Baldwin
at the Myaamia Center,
which is at the Miami
University in Ohio
and he has led the revitalized--
the reclamation efforts
for the Myaamia language.
And one of the things that they have
developed is this tool to be able
to manage digital surrogates,
annotate them, analyze them,
translate, whatever it is that is
necessary for that given manuscript.
And so, an output in a
dictionary format or another way.
So now we're working to try to
figure out how we can use this tool
to present it at a
Breath of Life Institute
and allow the participants take that
tool with them and be able to carry
out the work once they leave.
So, they can still leave
overwhelmed but with a tool
where they can start plowing away in
a methodological systematic manner.
So we're learning a lot about what
communities need and don't need,
what they know and don't
know and we're very mindful
that what we're asking
these communities to do
when we're giving them access to the
archive is that we're asking them
to become linguists, to become
folklorist, to become archivist,
to become ethnographers and
they're just average people.
So it's really important that we
understand what access really means.
It's not just letting them
come in for two weeks.
It's actually creating
an environment
where that access is meaningful
to whatever goals they have.
>> I second the comment this
was a great presentation.
My question is for Kelly.
I'm wondering if you could expand
on the concept of the many publics
that you described and talk
about that idea in the context
of the own-- your own collections
that you're building
in your program.
>> Kelly Navies: Sure.
It's a great question.
Well, I was actually thinking while
you were talking how important it is
to empower the communities to be
able to do that work because one
of the things that I'm getting
as essentially the only oral
historian right now are requests
from all over the country.
I know this person that needs to
be interviewed right now, tomorrow,
in addition to requests
from our own staff.
So, one of my biggest jobs is going
to be managing our internal request
with the request coming
from the public.
I'm someone who has a background
in community oral history.
And so it's really important
to me to create a situation
where the community can
come and be educated
to go back and do their own work.
They may or may not donate
those-- that work to us.
But I think it's important
to encourage people to donate
to their local historical
societies and libraries as well.
But the important thing is
that they have those skills
and the training to do that.
And I was really glad to hear
that that's one of the things
that you're doing because I'm
really looking forward to doing
that with our program as well.
So we have the communities.
We have churches.
We have different social
institutions,
activist groups like
Black Lives Matter.
I think-- groups like that that will
come to us that that is a public.
Then you have individuals, families.
We also have a genealogist.
One thing that's I
think relatively new is
that we have a permanent
oral historian
and a permanent professional
genealogist on staff.
There'll be a family
oral history center.
So, people will be trained to
not just conduct oral history
but to do genealogical research.
So there are a lot of different
ways that we're planning
to reach out to the public.
There'll be classrooms.
We'll invite classes in.
I really enjoy doing public
trainings and workshops.
So that's one of the
things that we're looking
for to getting started
as soon as possible.
Does that answer your question?
>> Sure.
>> Todd Harvey: I'm wondering
if it's in the cards for you
to use American Folklife
Center collections
as well in that outreach.
I mean can we kind of
piggyback on those communities?
>> Kelly Navies: I mean absolutely.
I think we love working with
the Library of Congress.
I mean I think yes.
I mean absolutely, these
are rich collections
and I'm excited [inaudible].
I collect records.
>> Lance Ledbetter: Oh, yeah.
>> Kelly Navies: I want to tell you.
I want to talk to you about that.
>> Todd Harvey: Well, Lance, how
does that fit into what you all do?
I mean what communities
are you building?
>> Lance Ledbetter: Well, I
think, you know, since we started,
you know, every release
I think we're up to--
We're over 50 releases now.
And, you know, what we try to do
is stretch maybe what our audience
might expect.
You know, we try to explain
to them why it's important
and not everything, like we
kind of look at our fan base
as being adventurous listeners.
So not everything is going to be for
everyone but with each new release,
we hopefully will bring
more people to the audience.
You know, more people to sort of
the, you know, what's coming next,
you know, kind of build excitement.
And I think that's what
we try to bring, you know,
to archives that we work
with is like trying to figure
out what is the hooks that might
help get people that read, you know,
pitchfork or mojo or whatever it
is, what's going to express to them
like maybe I should check that out.
>> Todd Harvey: Well, how did you
do that with the Morocco book set?
>> Lance Ledbetter: I mean sort--
You know, I knew Paul Bowles,
the fact that he made
those recordings,
I knew that his name connected
to it was going to be, you know,
a big seller but I
didn't realize how big.
You know, his fan base is very
obsessed with him, you know,
and they want his liner note.
They'll buy a box set just to
get his liner notes, you know.
So it was a-- It's a
little surprising how,
you know, his fan base reacted.
But it was great.
I mean, it was really exciting.
>> Todd Harvey: Did you have
a question, Alan, or comment?
>> Alan: I just have
a general question.
The phrase oral history
has been used widely.
Sorry.
>> Yes.
>> Alan: Today and I'm interested
in the history of that phrase
because I think it would
tell us something about,
you know, how it was generated.
And oral history, well, history is
either oral or written, you know,
literally speaking and-- But to
invent the phrase oral history,
a lot of people say, well, that--
What's the name of that historian
from Columbia invented oral history.
Well, that-- I didn't
have any way to deny that.
But on the other hand,
I ran across a letter
and Alan Lomax is correspondent
to the library here from the '30s
that used the phrase oral history.
And so the phrase is older
than the Columbia professor
who was post World War II.
So does anybody have any
insight into that and--
>> Kelly Navies: That's
a big question.
I don't know who first coined
the phrase but you are correct,
it doesn't go back to
the early '20s and '30s.
And is Doug Boyd still here?
He may know.
I think it's an interesting
question though
because people often misunderstand
what oral history is and obviously
within this group of people we
all have an idea or definition.
We may not all agree on
it but we do have an idea.
But when I'm out in the world and
I tell people I do oral history,
the first thing they think is you
tell stories, you're a storyteller.
And I have to-- I always
have to explain to them,
no, that's not what I do.
But it's interesting that that's
the first thing that they think
when they hear oral history.
So it does make you wonder about the
term itself and how accurate it is
in describing what we do, that's--
But in terms of the actual evolution
of that term, that's
a good question.
Guha.
>> Guha: This has nothing to do
with oral histories
although only tangentially.
So you all have been a
very nice, polite and not
to say also good looking bunch and--
>> Kelly Navies: Thank you.
>> Guha: -- that's all
been very kind of you
to speak so nice of the archives.
Maybe if it's not too impossible
a question, could you talk perhaps
about what are your
biggest frustrations
with using archival materials?
Because we certainly working at
the library, work in the museum,
working at the archives of
the American Folklife Center,
we need to know from the user
base not just the fan base
as to what we do and
what we could do better.
Sorry, I mean, any-- and all of you.
>> Kelly Navies: That's
for the audience.
>> Yeah, well--
>> Guha: And you guys, I guess
since you're the principal users--
>> Kelly Navies: OK.
>> Guha: -- users but also
from other folks here.
Take it away.
>> Kelly Navies: You're trying
to get us in trouble up here.
>> Todd Harvey: We're trying
to provide better service.
>> Kelly Navies: Yes,
somebody else start.
>> John Bishop: Well, I hardly ever
try and get anything out of you, so.
But you're always extremely
pleasant to work with.
Well, that-- You know what--
for advice or fixing your
recording and things like that.
It's-- I don't know,
and I can tell you
about a Canadian experience I had.
I was making-- no.
No.
>> Kelly Navies: I have tried
to access the collections
as an outsider before I came
to work for the Smithsonian.
I'm also a librarian by training.
I think that a challenge is deciding
what that accurate search term is.
And that's even for me as a
librarian when you're trying
to narrow down if you're looking
for photographs or you're looking
for a specific interview, I
think that is always a challenge
and I'm not-- I think I know
that's something that we're--
we work on in cataloging.
But that is-- That's an area that
we are-- We need to work on more.
So, all of us because we're
trying to do the same thing now
in the museum to make people
aware of the collection
and find what it is that
they're looking for.
How do you know for
example that Freeman--
I mean although we do have
metadata that list certain topics,
but you would necessarily
know Freeman Hrabowski talks
about Emmett Till just by
knowing that his interviews
in our collection for example.
So we have to find ways to
make that information easier
for the public to [inaudible].
>> As a video guy, maybe for
Mr. Bishop but also audio files.
In this day and age it seems like
we're going to shorter and shorter,
shorter sound bit-- bites
and things like that.
How important do you feel it
is to kind of document things
in a longer form and maybe
an unedited, unvarnished
and let people have maybe their full
say because you're seeing shorter
and shorter sound bites in the
media and things like that.
So how important is for
multiple places to give
like the full unedited maybe
unvarnished look into our history
so people get a full
capsule of it, do you feel.
>> John Bishop: I'm
working on two films now.
One is with Jake Homiak at the
Smithsonian Anthropology Department.
And with Rastafarian elders who
are very loquacious and difficult
to understand, you know,
they're going to need some
subtitling outside the
Jamaican community.
And I've gone back and forth in my
own thinking and talking with Jake
about alternative ways
of presenting it.
They all need-- each
of the interviews we did require
some trimming and they go all
over the map and then
they come back.
So there should be some, you know,
consolidating to make it flow
like a, you know, coherent piece.
But it might be more
useful to have it.
There's a series of things 10
minutes or even a 20-minute one
with some annotations going with it.
And they get this hyper--
more of a hypertext in,
because no one is going
to watch 90 minutes
and I'm not sure we could ever
cut it down to 90 minutes.
Are you familiar with
the concept of this new--
the smallest narrative unit?
This is-- There's a movement
to build platforms
for dealing with this.
So people can pull the small
narrative units together
and weave their own piece.
I don't have much confidence that
people will have the patience
for that, but it's an
interesting idea in thinking
when you have large
bodies of material,
what's going to be the
smallest narrative units
that you can use possibly
to use in multiple ways
or string in multiple ways.
>> Todd Harvey: Friends, I think
that we have reached the camera man,
that he's asking his questions
means that we've done our job
that we've saturated this
audience with thought and ideas.
And I thank you all very
much for joining me today.
[ Applause ]
>> Kelly Navies: So
great to meet you.
>> John Bishop: It's
great to meet you and--
>> Steve Winick: So just in
closing, I'd like to kind
of reiterate something that
my colleague Todd Harvey said,
which is what a privilege
it is to work at a place
like the American Folklife
Center where we have
such wonderful collections and such
wonderful people who are dedicated
to making these collections
accessible to everyone.
And not only can we bring a group of
wonderful people like this together
for a whole day as Todd said.
We hope to be able to do so for a
whole 1.5 days because we are going
to continue this tomorrow of course.
And tomorrow we're going to
be talking about two sort
of separate communities
that have issues that--
or whose oral narratives
and whose material has it--
have issues for collectors
and for archivist.
And those are indigenous
communities and veterans.
So we'll be talking specifically
about our indigenous collections
and about the Veterans
History Project tomorrow.
So we welcome you back tomorrow
to hear about those materials.
But we'd also like to thank a
whole lot of people for today.
So first of all I'd
like to thank the staff
of the American Folklife Center
who's done such a great job
in putting this together.
Particularly those people who
you saw up here on the stage,
but also a number of people like
Thea Austin who does a lot of work
on these events but does
not get seen on the stage.
So we'd like to thank them as well.
[ Applause ]
We'd like to thank
all of the speakers
from today including this
wonderful panel here.
There have just been such
great ideas being thrown around
and so many different ideas
and so much to think about.
So we'd really like to thank
everyone who spoke today.
A round of applause
for them as well.
[ Applause ]
We'd like to thank our sound
crew and our video crew.
They're helping us get this together
and put it on the web as I said
so that this like the archival
materials that we're talking
about will be accessible.
And that's a really important thing.
So we'd like to thank them as well.
And finally, one thing that
came up again and again
in our discussions today was how
the Library of Congress goes about
and working with all this material.
And one thing that we should say is
that the American Folklife Center
is not, you know, an isolated unit.
We actually work within
a library that has a lot
of resources available for us to
work with including a whole ITS team
that puts things like this on
the web and also a whole web team
that puts our materials on the web.
So there is just a whole lot of
people throughout the Library
of Congress in all the
divisions that we work
with that we really couldn't
do our jobs without them.
So we'd like to thank them as well.
And finally, we would like to thank
you for coming and participating
in this in all the ways that you've
done and we really want you to,
as I said, continue to
participate tomorrow.
So we look forward to
having you here tomorrow.
Now, I would like to point out
that the wall has been removed.
We've broken the third wall.
And this means that-- or the
fourth wall I guess I should say.
And this means that behind
there you will find a reception.
And any of you of course
who have signed
up for the dinners will
be proceeding to them
after the reception is over.
So now it's time to think about all
those wonderful issues that came
up within your discussions and
remember the people that you wanted
to ask a particular question of and
find those people at the reception
and we'll continue chatting then.
So once again, I'm Steve Winick
for the American Folklife Center
and we will see you again tomorrow.
But for the moment let's
hang out and have some fun.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.